what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game ever in class
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you've watched two
or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
um so a couple announcements before we
start the show the first being that we
have two new clips channels the first is
just pearly clips which you guys got to
50k in a month
and then pearl daily which you got to
10k in like two weeks
um so make sure you go subscribe to both
of those the links to those are in the
description on top of that we have our
membership tiers the first gets you to
be a part of the live chat we're leaving
it open today anyone can be a part of
the live chat but i'm sorry we got to
make living here so on saturday we are
turning that back on to members only so
sign up for the live chat so you can be
a part of it the next tier is you get to
see the first look at our behind the
scenes penthouse we just moved in we're
filming it on what do we say monday
blessing
yeah monday we're going to film it so if
you want to get a first behind the
scenes look sign up for that it's a cool
place right guys
um so that's under um the ten dollar
tier the third tier you get to connect
with us on social media and the fourth
tier you get to do a one-on-one call
with me once a month um some people use
that to tell me their problems
other people which you know cool but
other people use it to grow on youtube
which is my favorite thing to use that
for so you guys should sign up on top of
that go follow my instagram it's just
dot pearly things i think i'm shadow
band and you have to type out the whole
thing it's kind of weird but make sure
it's just after just you put a dot and
then pearly things i'm almost a 50k on
instagram and
so um they took away my first tick tock
my second tick tock and my third tick
tock but tick tock number four just hit
100k in two weeks you can't get rid of
me
you can't get rid of me i'll be back on
the app
um so that's just
pearlythings.4 and i am on my final
warning for that account so i feel like
they might take that one
um so if they take that one just
pearlythings.5
you guys got me to like i think i'm at
15k on that so
uh decent the also thank you guys for
350 000 subscribers we just hit that
like two days ago um on top of that we
have a members only live that is going
to be next week and dm eddie if you want
to come on the show the link to his
instagram is in the description
so um today we have a lovely panel shout
out to you guys i'm a big clapper i'm a
big clapper
um so everyone go around say your name
your age your relationship status um and
where you're from you can start and then
go around okay i'm tiana i'm 25. i am
single
my name is jennifer i'm 23 years old and
i am currently in a relationship
my name is gloria i'm 29 years old and
i'm currently in a relationship
my name is the gaffer i'm 28 years old
and i'm in a relationship
my name is china i'm 38 years old
i just recently met the sweetest thing
so i'm in a relationship
and i'm from north london
um my name is tl t marie i'm 23 and i'm
single
i think this is the most like taken
panel we've ever had it's usually all
single people um okay so today's topic
as is has instagram ruined modern women
so um i have a question for the panel
how has instagram changed dating
oh we got girls first or boys we'll let
the girls go first
you just pick the that seat typically
goes first okay um
put it this way us boys we think we we
think it does
i think i think he does i think he's
changed how
more exposure more accessed
um
more things to do with your life on a
screen
meaning you want to
i think the prior i think
women don't look at making a family and
building a home anymore it's more about
traveling and finding adventures and
you know you know looking for mystery
places but doing something else for
their life but not
doing
you know not being
how can i say how can i say it's not
it's not
the patients have the patience
everyone's patience has gone now so put
it like this right
um i think we're trying to say so with
instagram's instagram social media has
created a lot of options um it's
creating a lot of well perceived options
um so it's
whereas before you would you know if you
was a pretty girl you wouldn't pretty
girl in your school um in your little
area or whatever and you had a local
local people that would have you know
approached you but now with instagram
you have more attention from everywhere
and what it tends to do is
it can um
it can inflate girls the perception of
what actually
um they value or
what's available to them so for example
if you're in a relationship with a girl
and um she has an open instagram and i
mean she can get attention from all
different types of men now particularly
if you're just in a relationship and
she's a girlfriend she's not your wife
and remember you know if she's she
hasn't got a ringer now technically
you're just you're just there right so
instagram just creates a place where
women can get opportunities and get
messages and they can get distractions
from all different places and that's
just one one aspect of it we can go way
further than that but with social media
it just creates some
more interest what do you guys think i
agree what he just said yeah yeah i do
agree
100
i think um
sort of like
it's
in terms of it's ruined them would you
say it's ruined a modern woman yeah oh
okay yeah so like
if we're looking at the women in the
past let's say you're within a community
you only know the people within your
community so if you
have you know done dynamite for example
everyone in that community is going to
know but now it's like you have the
whole world
to just free up yourself
basically so i think
it it's definitely
more exposure more you're seeing you're
you're having a lot more like people to
compare yourself to as well and i think
that's problematic for self-esteem so
it's
the moving yeah
so do you think it makes women um have
lower self-esteem yeah a hundred percent
yeah depending on what you're comparing
yourself to other you're comparing
yourself to other women
and yeah so why are women so addicted to
it then i i've listened it's women that
do it to other women like yeah none of
us have ever asked you guys to get a bbl
none of us ever asked you guys to wear
not your natural hair none of it asked
you guys to put stuff into your lips
these are all things that you guys do
for you guys so but whenever a man talks
about it they'll say keep out our
women's businesses i saw our body right
that's fine but you have to understand
the things that these women are doing
you're creating insecurities between
yourselves because us as men we don't
want these things and the moment we say
we don't want these things it's like
keep out women women's business you know
what i'm trying to say to you
no but men
no but
men always say they don't want these
things but i okay like i'm not saying
i'm beyonce and i'm not saying i'm
freddie kruger ever but i have never
been moved to when i don't have makeup
on yeah i'd
never
i i've got outside i know people that
run to the shop in their headscarfs and
their whatever and they've never been
moved to and you have to understand the
woman that has that look of the bbl and
the long brazilian weave and they get
the more attention they get the most
attention
you can just see on screen do you think
it's relationship attention or sexual
attention
and i wouldn't and i wouldn't put makeup
in the same category as lip fillers in a
b yeah i was going to say that i would i
would say that i was going to get it
we'll give you makeup we'll give you
makeup
they do go for the rappers and the
footballers and the rappers and the
footballers that's the look that they go
for right but would you say the rappers
and the footballers are husbands looking
for wives
what they do watch them
do they
would you say would you say rappers
really have wives
or do they have like three baby bombers
i agree
and this is the thing if if you're if
you're looking at rappers and and and
footballers and people as your target
demographic then already what you're
saying is i have to be willing for a
certain type of behavior because you're
going like you're saying you're going
for the top guy right and the top guy is
going to do certain things and he's
going to look at certain things so for
us i'll say it again
and i'll make it loud us as men we want
you in your natural state because your
natural hair your natural nails your
natural
um
your natural lips these are things that
are going to be passed on the jeans to
my child so whatever you do nice nice
people like whatever you do that's how
you look but it's not really how you
look see when i wake up next to you in
the morning that's the real you and i
grew up in a house with three sisters
and my mom so i'm
i'm from my african um background so i'm
used to seeing women with day um in
their natural hair i'm used to seeing
women obviously covered and stuff stuff
like that so for me
i would actually
move to you with a head scarf on because
i would consider you to be beautiful
because my sister's built for a head
scarf on right but the problem is
all of these fakery and stuff is we got
to deal with it so of course if you've
got
brazil for as a black girl what have you
got chinese men called brazilian hair
coming out over here so for me i'll be
like you know just keep them keep the
normal hair even if what's that girl
with that afro what's her name
jas yeah as soon as i came i said oh i
love your hair
it's just because it just looked natural
she just looked natural so for us as men
they may tell you that's not what you
want but trust me you love a natural
woman that's sort of going back to what
you said actually is it a wife or is it
just sexual because like you would want
a wife
say the
the you know obviously like jess you
said yeah but
if you were sexually attracted yeah you
just smashed the thing with the
brazilian butt of course but
but now you're saying just smash if
you're talking smash versus wife now
it's completely different things now if
i'm gonna smash you then i don't really
care
about your hair because if
the week the we've come out in your hand
now you're not gonna be bothered about
that because that's gonna be experienced
you're gonna talk to your boy about and
say oh this is what happened but you
know you're not gonna care really more
than that yeah you say you need to say
something
um
no i was going to say i feel like
in terms of
the natural hair thing is i feel like
that is quite a big topic as well but i
feel like as black women nissan there
was a period of time when
eurocentric features were what was
promoted
cooley women were the ones who were
on magazines and the ones who we were
told that we are supposed to look like
you know what i mean so i feel like as a
woman a black woman growing up in a
society where from a young age we've
been programmed
to view beauty in a certain light
it's hard to
manipulate what it's hard to reprogram
what we've been manipulated to believe
we can teach our children
but as a as a person looking in the
mirror
and sometimes it's not even uh like i
feel like wearing fake hair sometimes
it's a protective
yeah my protective hair styling because
you don't know who what that person's
hair is underneath and we're not
necessarily in the right country in
climate as black people in general for
our hair to flourish and grow in
its natural state for all of us we're
not in our home country no i hear that
and what i'll say as a guy right is is
you can have a protective style but let
it be a protective style that is
matching towards your hairstyle or where
you're from so if you want to protect
your hair that's fine but have a have a
braid style have a corner style
extension style and that'll be more
natural so what we're just trying to
just say is either way natural always be
better for us as men but we're always
going to be told that fakery is what we
want when in actual fact we don't want
that but then men need to speak up on
that then we can't speak on women's
bodies
but women don't women don't listen to
men when they say what they want i just
said women women don't women don't
listen because when men say they want
thin women pure women
and and women don't listen they just say
that they're slut-shaming and they're
not body positive so it's like when men
even say what they want we don't care i
just think each of our own if you want
to wear a wig
if you want to wear
braids wear bricks i don't think like i
mean there's men out there that
generally like
women with the long brazilian hair and
afro and the braids when the men start
saying oh
we like a woman that's natural like
that's where women have an issue with it
but wait didn't you just say that men
should speak out on it and now you're
saying they can't i'm not saying but
when you start saying oh we only like
girls of natural hair like that can so
we're not allowed to have a preference
or something so what's happening again
is you say mention speak out and i speak
and i say you know what i like your hair
in that way but you know what actually
what i actually prefer is if your
natural state i think you look more
beautiful than that that's okay that's
okay saying that that's okay saying that
but when you start
putting it's okay saying it but when i
start saying it no when you start
putting oh that's what i prefer oh i
like that but it's my preference
preference is part i think i feel like i
thought i thought each to their own like
if i just say that we've been given the
choice as women exactly we have been
given choice i completely agree with
that but with that choice comes
repercussions
so the receiver of women is men
in that respect
if you want a man you should be willing
to see what that man needs now if that
is the case that that man is asking i
don't prefer women he was wearing hair
extensions he was wearing weaves that
doesn't match her natural skin color
then it is not your place as a woman to
tell that man that he is wrong for his
preference
would you say that um because i've heard
from guys when the girls have like more
of the fake stuff or the bbls or
whatever they put them more in like a
casual category just off the bat of
course
come on man
it's so mad to me that you thinking that
putting all these fakers gonna get your
man that she wants you and you even have
to understand the difference between
someone that wants you for one night and
someone that really wants you see if i
want you for one night i don't care what
you do see your wig can come off and
come up in the hand in the bedroom it
doesn't matter like it doesn't even if
it doesn't matter how you dress in
actual fact the more provocative they're
better because you're letting people
know what you're on but now if i'm
talking about you as my wife you know
all of these things that i want to eat
for one one night would be a red flag
for me there would be things that i
wouldn't i would i wouldn't really
really want and i just got to think that
women have to ask themselves what do
they want do you see if you want one
night that's fine do a certain thing but
if you actually want long term then the
things that you do for that one night
are going to affect you in the long term
you know what's interesting you said
that rappers prefer like the bbls and
stuff yeah i didn't know i didn't i said
rappers do go for the footballers they
go go for a certain look so
it does make sense that certain women
will have insecurities oh
this person wants that so i'm going to
go out to turkey or in the dominican
republic and get a bbl as well why do
you think we go to this extent to get
the attention from those men when
they're clearly not husbands
like very obviously not like
maybe
maybe i'm not talking for myself but
maybe it's the lifestyle that they want
like
just yeah instagram is a lot of them
it's about lifestyle okay and maybe yeah
yeah what would you say because they got
money
but that's what lifestyle means
but you say that yeah but you're
generalizing all footballers because
i've seen um was it marcus rashford's
football
a lot of people don't know this i
started my channel with rap reactions so
i used to do like whitest girl on earth
reacts to poo sheisty or like
or like whatever the
um i probably would have kept doing it
but it kept getting demonetized shout
out shout out youtube
but um i ended up doing a collab with um
i don't know if you know him but fredo
bang but not the uk one
yeah and i asked him during that i was
like be like
bbl or no but and like he picked no butt
that's only rapper i've ever met but
like i also think if you if you look at
rappers or footballers or these types of
people as the people that you're gonna
then
you're really setting yourself up to
fail really because these aren't never
these these were never the
the types of people you you would
consider as husband materials so it
depends what you want i don't i don't
know like obviously a lot of people here
in relationships
but even when you wasn't or
prior it's like if you want a guy that's
going to be in in the top percentile and
it's going to do a very highly paid job
would have got a high paid school then
you've got to be accepted that these
guys are going to move different yeah
that's totally true and on that point
these men are not men that we see
normally in the public i mean i'm not
going to walk out on the street and just
randomly meet a rapper or like a
a
a
fortune 500 businessman
so let's take rapper out of it for a
second right let's just talk about the
normal guy the normal guy doesn't want
you in the bbl the normal guy doesn't
want fake lips the normal guy doesn't
want fake rest wrestling normal guy
doesn't want doesn't want fake hair the
normal guy doesn't want doesn't want a
high body count he doesn't this is what
the normal guy doesn't want and we can
look
and even in the most famous people they
wouldn't want that either and it would
also say kim kardashian yeah you can see
all the trouble she's going through now
yeah yeah like literally it's all it's
all coming apart when her kids at age
where it's actually going to be when
they start asking questions
as soon as they hit
secondary school that's that's when it
will start happening yeah really start
happening to their kids do you think
that social media has made girls more
promiscuous
yes yes absolutely yeah why
because of the instant gratification
women can put pictures of themselves
online wearing next to nothing and get a
plethora of men commenting saying oh
you're so beautiful you're so wonderful
and then they carry that into their real
lives as though that's something that
men actually genuinely think about them
when they walk out on the street but
it's it's really not the same type of
gratification no but you women support
it though you like you women actually
applaud whole behavior i would like to
okay okay
but the majority of women on social
media even the blogs they they applaud
it and if you ever try to comment in the
comments you get do you know what you
get told as a man it's the same thing or
misogyny or stay at women's business you
don't tell a woman what to do
it always comes after the same thing and
i
i got three sisters and all of my
sisters are married all my sisters were
child um and my brother's married as
well so my parents are still together um
and i grew up in that unit right so
i always think to myself what if my
sister was ever doing any one of these
things that you got i would just pull it
to the side and say like what are you
doing so the fact that girls don't
actually pull their friends to the side
like you know what i'm trying to say to
you like we had to we had to pull her
onto the podcast because she didn't want
to get on the podcast but she has a
really good point of view and i'm saying
to her literally like no you need to you
need to tell people like what like your
opinion because we need girls that
actually get what we're saying and are
willing to be vocal about it but all
these girls are going to say he's a pic
she's a pick me
well i think it says something about the
competition there is between women as
general i mean like if you look at the
globe in general there are more women on
the planet than there are men
so if every man was to get paid off
today i'm sure we've all had this
talking point many times before if all
men were to get paid off today there'd
be a full woman left over it is a
competition it really is no but if you
want the footballers and if you want the
rappers then what about the normal man
it's not it's not just about the
footballers though it's a competition
for every man in general in order to get
paired up if that's what you want
like even when you look at all these
girls go look at their instagram
comments right look at the likes look
even when they're in a relationship
you'll see all these men commenting like
and being simps in the comments right
but end of the day a lot of times you
could just pick one of these guys and
and live your best life they
literally in public saying how much they
want you but you don't pick none of
these guys in actual fact you pick
someone that's gonna
be
be having access to so many women that
you actually can look at you like
actually maybe i don't i don't need this
but all the guys in the comments in the
dm's you girls ignore them
you literally ignore them why well isn't
that part of the saying that women want
the top 10 of men the men that are
earning like maybe six figures or six
foot tall or so on so forth the ones
that look that good on instagram look
there's one two three four there's five
women in here if only one of if only one
of us in here is that guy you can't all
get them you have some of you're gonna
have to concede absolutely but i think
the point is is that if there was a man
here that was six foot earning six
figures and he presented himself as such
hello
if we got to know each other better i do
believe that most women would be wanting
to go for that man rather than the other
men simply because he stands head and
shoulders above all other men like i'll
give you another example that could be
um like i've seen it in my personal life
i've got a lot of cousins that are
bodybuilders and they have amazing
bodies they don't get instant
gratification the same way on social
media that one of my cousins
he was female who maybe doesn't work out
as much gets instant gratification when
she posts a bikini picture why is that
yeah because men just want to bang you
absolutely true so
because women are the gateway to sexism
yeah so so but you can't get excited
about a man comment and you're giving
like this is the thing it says it's mad
to me because if you get if you actually
get excited that a man slides in your
dms or gives you a compliment then you
are you don't actually you have
i don't want to say your low value
basically if if that's what gets you
going then that life's going to be
really hard for you because you're going
to go through life and then these types
of women you're going to actually
actually feel sorry for these absolutely
because you a lot of men can lie to you
and this is how a lot of these women end
up getting damaged because they go
through quite ditsy quite not knowing
what's going on men say all these things
and you've got to remember there's two
types of men right there's there's men
that on their purpose that well there's
more than two types of men but we're
going to talk about mendel on their
purpose but and that want to get out
there that actually being productive
that are getting money that could be six
foot that could be all of these things
that you think of but for some reason
you believe these men want to be outside
they don't want to be outside what they
want to be they want to be inside with a
good woman but because you look at the
other guys that do that type of thing
you automatically think these men
they're going to cheat then you have the
other men look these men
are always going to be in dm's they're
always going to be simply for this but
you none of you women pick these men and
when i say simple i don't mean they're
not going to be good men i just mean
they could give you everything you want
bar the six foot bar some of these other
things they're six figures but they
could be a good man and they would love
you but you disregard them so if only
one of us is that guy let's say that's
me in this room and the rest of the men
what about the rest of them and why
don't they get a shot i think you're
generalizing because that's exciting
yeah i would say he's not because i
think dating app data allows women to be
very confident no i think dating app
data allows women to be very honest
about what they like and what they want
and women only swipe right between five
on the high end twenty percent of the
time
and so where men swipe right fifty
percent of the time
i don't even use dating apps i will
never use one either and any girl that's
been on a date night for me for the
streets
go ahead listen
you have to remember right
now i'm just injured how many times uh
how many times do you get moved to in a
week let's say you just go you go london
transport a week how many times do you
think you get moved to a week
just honestly ladies just just throw a
figure once a week once a week
same you so once a week a man moves you
once a week she's even less than that
probably less once a month
so when you're outside in the public a
man will only approach you once every
single month so like 12 times a year i
can count this year i can't count i know
already you're capping
i know you're capping i understand look
i'm gonna be honest i'm gonna be honest
like if we're gonna do this be honest
like you only get me through once a week
in the public and you catch train you go
come on man let's be real
once a day maybe you know what i'm
trying to say to you so so so
be honest
i don't know
okay cool so
when in real life with women right
whether or not they get moved to once a
week once a day
when you go on to social media put
yourself on a dating app you now put
yourself as meat you're not selling
yourself i consider that selling
yourself right so whereas before
natural interactions many will actually
have to come up to you and actually have
to have that bit of you know confidence
let me speak to you that little bit of
where you can smell a man you can see a
man you can pick up all the environments
now you just put yourself and said yo
look at me right and so when you do that
it says to me you're cheaping yourself
so my so not only can i see you my boys
can see you now automatically right and
so for us when we see a girl that's on
dating apps a lot of my friends are on
there and they just it's for hookups
they're just having sex with girls right
and girls say oh i'm not on there i'm
not on there for that and my friend met
there
you know i know someone that got married
on the dating app and that's like the
lottery that's like saying i know
someone that played the lottery and they
want everybody to know someone that
played the lottery one but how many
people played the lottery ever since
actually it's actually just devil's
advocates the number one way that people
are meeting up or the number one way
relationships are starting nowadays is
online and that's why i take that like
dating apps like because a lot of people
will discredit the dating app stats
because they'll say like oh no like not
everyone uses it for relationships or
for that stuff but like that's the
number one way people are meeting
nowadays i've i've met two people
actually that got married and met in a
dating app
i'm not saying you're incorrect i would
i would guess a ton of that is for like
i would guess a ton of that's very
casual but but if you're surveying
people on where did you meet your
partner and the number one way is is
dating apps like i can't where did you
get married to your partner should be
the question like because no it's the
same so it's it's it's the same so yeah
so for me every guy that i know on
dating app is not getting married on a
dating app no no we'll actually say i
met my girl in actually if you did you
would keep that quiet because i think it
depends on the dating app personally
yeah because there are some people who
pay money to get away from certain
people dating apps so for example
there's e-harmony where you actually
have to pay a subscription you're paying
to get away from a certain demographic
of people by doing that because let's be
real if you're just looking for casual
help out the likelihood is you're not
trying to pay money to go on e-harmony
for a casual hiker i don't like i don't
really care either way but i i just
can't like overlook the stats that i
that i've seen you know what i'm saying
but for me yeah and okay so the stats
that you're seeing okay cool yeah the
stats but where i'm coming from i can we
are not meeting our wives on dating apps
and in actual fact the friends that on
dating apps are telling me all the fun
and sex they're having on dating apps
right and they have to be having sexual
women that want to be having sex because
you have to understand women are very
empowered now and there's a lot of
feminists and and and um strong
would you consider instagram a dating
app
okay it is a dating app but you're not
on there to date so it's different so if
you meet someone organically through the
comments through that stuff that's
different but when you actively put
yourself on this say swipe and tap in
it's different so let's say i meet you
today and it's going really well it's
going really well you know i'm talking
to you we speaking for a week i'm like
yo i'm saying to my boy g-shot man i've
met the girl of my dreams man like like
everything's going i can't wait to see
her then you know i mean then you know
what it is um the gaffer he then gets on
the app the the following week and all
of a sudden she gets a bit bit colder
because she's had a better match now but
for the last week i've been thinking
i've met my woman i only met my woman
because she hadn't had a better match
and that's what happens in real life she
wouldn't have that many options but
because literally she's a girl and every
single day a new hot match all of a
sudden i'm competing with guys i haven't
you know the types of guys i'm competing
with i don't even know see i would say
that instagram's like the same
like i i think it's the same i think i
would guess
like more people meet on instagram than
that if you want to dance
i don't think it's organic if you're
looking up a girl's ass pic
i think that also
contradicts the point that you made
earlier that you meet naturally in
public but then you have this instant
gratification from instagram like how
can you say it's a natural on instagram
because
it is because
because listen they said there's a big
difference in doing a dating profile and
saying look this is my age sex my
location whatever it is this is
their description no no wait listen
there's a big difference between between
that and you having an instagram for
business for whatever just having a
normal what percent of girls have
instagram for business
for me there's a big difference there's
a big difference i'm being honest
because because
not my friends wouldn't just
automatically find your instagram and
start speaking to you when you put
yourself on these apps all in the
algorithms all of a sudden do you know
how many friends x's we see on instagram
we're like oh oh sorry on um on on apps
yeah and then we're like okay cool the
relationship ended she's in the 30s now
so we know where she's ended up on the
day and we just laugh because we already
know what she's about to go through so
once you end up on the on a date and
that
why would you be on a dating app if if
if you were really that you don't find
quality women on date
you can find them on instagram
no i'm not saying you find them on
instagram but i'm saying on a dating app
i would think that if i was on a date
and i'll be realistic and i would know
i'm not going to find my wife on there
and i would tell any guy that's on there
bro like you know yeah fair enough fair
enough
but i i feel like instagram's the same
thing no it's not
i i i think instagram's the same thing i
think all social media is the same thing
i think i think the difference is if
if a man has options he uses social
media to uh explore his options if a man
doesn't have options uses social media
to find love and that's the difference
but when people say oh yeah i use social
media and i found a woman on my dreams
there's a reason why he's on social
media and he didn't go to a bar or a
club and find
the woman that he wanted i think every
boy does dream about meeting that
perfect woman in that perfect place they
might not admit it but they will say
that yeah when i'm young i want to get a
nice wife getting my nice family there
build on my clan
but the last thing we're thinking about
is i want to find my wife on tinder
that's the last thing
will not go on social media to find a
relationship yeah facts
never no that's the difference a man
with options in a manner that doesn't
have options a man that doesn't have
options we'll go on social media to look
for love why would a woman why would the
quality woman even be on there
advertising herself like oh just pick
like the swipe and and you can get him
like why would you do that if you was
really that girl every single day you
step into the like you'll be dodging
them like trust me the bad ones are
dodging them so i think this is going to
go into my next topic of the show
so um i made a presentation for you guys
is the whiteboard coming back
i got a whiteboard guys it's very
exciting very exciting so hold up i
gotta
so
my next thing i wanted to talk about is
cheating right
instagram has changed the game for
cheating
you could
download
you know an app have a girl over or a
guy over like that
you can
but
there's some gray areas when it comes to
relationships so i decided as a group we
can figure it out
what's cheating and what's not cheating
all of them i can see
all right all right everything i can see
sleeping in the center
i bring it like this my mom could never
be so brazen
[Laughter]
when i talk i talk in death all right i
got you
thank you
oh i can put that yeah
okay
okay wait where's my pointer
yes
it is so i have a pointer because i
think i look cooler with it um so today
since men and women women are different
we're gonna have different categories so
we have cheating
or not cheating
all right the boys and the girls so
liking another girl's picture cheating
or not cheating it's an ass pic
or for the girls
it's a shirtless pick
what's your definition of cheating not
cheating
just like sorry i'm gonna do the
majority everyone everyone all right
if a guy likes a girl's ass pic raise
your hand if you think it's cheating
okay not cheating okay i'm surprised how
was that
all right
so i'm gonna i'm gonna write down
not
yes yeah i'm good with that yeah all
right all right so for the girls liking
a guy's shirtless selfie
who's who thinks he's cheating
[Laughter]
guys
but i'll be honest i'll be honest with
you right now
no that's not an oxymoron to be honest
with you i don't i would i wouldn't be
liking the girl's ass picture on the
ground i don't do that but i don't i
still don't consider it it's not
something i would do but i don't
consider it to be cheating but you your
girl should not be liking a a man's body
so so your girl you you said you have a
girlfriend yeah so she likes another
guy's shirtless picture yeah i'm not
gonna like that
is it over
is it over oh no no it's not cheering
no but it's that's that's
okay so so should i put down red flags
yes
but not cheating no not cheating but red
flag well then you can put down red
flags
[Laughter]
also if anyone has any i do have a back
of this that i can write it down don't
worry we're gonna have some more
number two
answering a dm so
for the boys he gets a message from a
girl saying you're fine you're cute
whatever and he says thank you that's
not cheating no because it depends if
there's any keys
or more oh that's it oh caveat yeah okay
cool yeah let me finish yeah that's what
i was gonna say and keeps chatting they
never meet up but he keeps
cheating
i wouldn't say he's cheating but it's
it's a it's a red flag if he does it no
it's cheating it's cheating raise your
hand if you think it's cheating class
it's bad it is bad because free messages
or more in any circumstance because
that's not cheap i just think you
shouldn't be talking to anyone else if
you're serious about them yeah i think i
think that you think that you're going
to get married to this person in the
future that you want to bear that
of course you should not be liking
anyone else just like that you don't
even say thank you you shouldn't be
talking to anyone
just leave it as it is they can have
they can feel however they want to feel
about you but you shouldn't be talking
to them if you're genuinely serious
about the person you're dating all right
it's official it's on the whiteboard yes
so for the girls 100 cheating if you go
with plastic raise your hand cheating
raise your hand out
absolutely all right all right
even saying i've got a man is cheating
all right i wouldn't say for boys is
cheating i would not say that at all
because faithful girls don't reply so
even if you even to reply i've got a man
that's cheating because if he was
faithful you even got a reply you just
air it just air it you keep it in your
request to reply
uh or are you black or basically yeah
but play for girls don't reply yeah
favorite goes blue okay okay
so
all right posting a thirst trap so
you got a girl she posts a thirst trap
why ass pic
is that cheating oh no we're doing the
boys first i'm sorry i'm sorry you guys
got a man he posts uh a shirtless pic
it's not the same
men and women not sexualized the same
way yeah
it's not he's not gonna listen
just as long as i don't see the v in the
picture then no the v is in it oh
i'm saying i i treat you he has no
business it's not it's not a business
it's just purely attraction it's just
trappy
yeah to be honest with when man do that
i don't ever rate that anyway like so
okay so raise your hand if you think
it's cheating
um
so red flag but not
like
i think it's red flag for other reasons
not that you know what i mean can i just
say your mind come and pull some topless
pictures
yeah
okay
that's a bit um so then for the girls
opposite
so ass picture
it's like one of the thong bikinis it's
not even just a bikini it's a thong
bikini i i i i'm calling any other way
about it pretty little things send it to
her
so we're all together on this cheating
okay
oh gosh i have bad handwriting but see
i'm i'm helping save relationships now
this is the everyone can know exactly
where the line is they're going to
screenshot this wait hold on hold on
hold on where are we cheating not but
ready like
so basically i'll here you go so don't
worry class i'll explain so
the reason i put a red flag this means
you can get away with it you won't get
dumped but it is a red flag so it'll be
like
i don't really like that i'll keep an
eye on it but the relationship isn't
over
where this cheating means relationship
over dumped
my hater
may i ask why is that so different for
boys as it is girls um for the posting
thirst traps
well i mean we we came together as a
group i was just writing down what the
group said i would say it's because like
women are more sexualized than men are
like i wouldn't want like we sexualize
ourselves but like
men are more visual than women are so i
would say it's like a different effect
would you not also say that's part of
the point that sex is part of the the
gift that women have to give to men in
the respect that women are the bearers
of sex men can't really have sex with
the women unless
you know but otherwise
sex is sexist 50 50. so you get
something i get something like you don't
like this there's just there's this
thing that women say i'm giving you sex
no like yeah but i'm giving you
something back so
women like sex and men like sex so let's
not act like you're actually giving me
something
unless you're a virgin that's the only
time you're giving me something if not
you're just giving me something you're
giving to someone else you misunderstood
my point you're not going to have sex
with a woman unless she tells you you
can have sex with her right yeah okay
so my point being is that it's a very
sexualized position that women come from
when it comes to relationships that's
why it's it's so much more graphic when
a woman comes forward and is naked on
instagram almost in her videos because
nobody wants to see man's dicks that's
the truth of the matter it's not pretty
like it's not nobody wants to see it
like it's like if you go and set like
women always talk about these dick pics
like it's the most i don't understand
why a man will do it because you just
sense that into a woman and women don't
want to see that but a woman's body
actually other women like women's bodies
and they talk about women's bodies no
man starts talking about another man's
body and if they do that but the point
is why is that because we come from a
place where sex is what we have to go on
but women sexualize themselves like i
don't look at like i said before like
men we value we found youth purity and
um loyalty right that's one of some of
the things that we value right none of
them are sex but this thing where girls
got to be like oh what the sex saying
right like that's because you think to
yourself you need to come or something
but i've said it before and i'll say it
again when a girl is doing that mad
thing bro you know that mad thing like
you're saying that got 3000. but all you
can think to yourself is where did she
learn this like you're enjoying it like
but i'm not trying to wear fart you know
i'm saying i would like to teach my wife
that but she's coming and she's coming
all prepared that's not something men we
value but for one night yeah of course
i'm going to value that i want to tell
my boys about it but i would never work
that okay so can i ask in that respect
then what in a relationship does a woman
have to offer you
in general what does a woman offer you
in a relationship
so how do you mean
in that respect what does a woman
actually offer you
because i i don't see any other part in
this apart from what a woman has to
offer you apart from maybe what she can
give to you in terms of her mind but a
big part of loyalty but yes that's true
but i just said a second ago
that is gratification for
here yeah not because we can vote i'm
sure all the men in this room can agree
that you have a level of testosterone
that when your woman is next to you
naked you're going to get
aren't you yeah but i just i just i'm
really confused as to what you're
arguing yeah we're talking about it
no i no i no it's okay i just i don't i
would have something to say if i
understood what you're talking about so
i just don't understand what you're
arguing
maybe i could clarify a little bit yeah
i think that a lot of what a woman has
to offer on man is through sex i mean we
bear children for you through sex don't
we no but we have sex such like if you
think about all the time you spend with
your girl or your partner think about
how much time you actually have sex with
him like if that's all you have to offer
it's going to be very boring for them
and that's what we use girls that you're
gonna meet for one that stands for
because that's what they're offering
right like you have to offer so much
more than sex and
and
and something has been lost along the
way i don't know whether or not your
people's fathers or mothers haven't told
them but you have to be there's so much
other things that men want other than
sex yeah like i think like i think of my
mom like she created like traditions for
our whole family that we would do and it
it might sound simple but it was like a
lot of work for her to put together
these like family traditions that
everyone would do so like i feel like a
wife creates a home
more than anything and like
yeah that's like that put it this way
what can you offer more than what a
prostitute can't
put it this way if you already if you
really can bring sex to the table and
you think that's all we care about then
you're going down the wrong road
yeah i believe my point was
misunderstood i'm not saying that all
women have to offer us sex but what i am
saying is is that if a man were to get
married to a woman and she didn't
provide those duties in that respect i
think it would be very appreciative no
she has to provide sex that's like dude
so i think it should work on the same
grounds in a basic relationship where
you're just girlfriend and boyfriend
you're trying to walk towards no because
you shouldn't be giving your boyfriend
the same thing you give to your husband
this is where the problems happen this
is literally where the problems happen
like you give to random guys one-night
guys and short-term relationship
boyfriends the same
actually more than what you give to your
husband because you don't give him your
purity do you and a lot of the times
what tends to happen is when you meet a
girl and they say to you um you know
i've got insecurities or you know i just
don't trust people this is because of
previous relationships right so when
they say oh you know i've learned things
i've learned sex or whatever
that is for us like we don't value that
because along with that sexual skills
that you've learned you've learned you
had a lot of hurt and a lot of trauma
now i'm dealing with this i would rather
a girl who hasn't gone and dated all
these different guys because she thought
they were footballers and rappers or
whatever and these aren't the guys that
were ever gonna wear for you then by the
time you actually start coming back to a
normal level and you meet a guy like me
i'm dealing with a reminiscence of this
and this is what happens
as a man in his 30s um that wants to get
married that comes from a family that
that everyone is married with with child
that is something i aspire to and the
reason i haven't got it is because i
keep meeting problematic um boss [ __ ]
who don't want us who believe submission
is some type of um negative word but but
there's a lot of power and femininity
you guys don't understand how much in
actual fact we go to work for you
everything we do is for you and you
don't even realize it
well i i'm not coming from the prospects
that you know women who only have sex to
offer and coming from the prospects that
if you're in a relationship with someone
you're going to have agreements on you
you're going to say okay i require this
are you going to be able to agree with
that and from that you're going to say
like okay well yes or no that's not
going to be what it is for people isn't
it right so all i'm saying is is that i
perfectly understand that for some
people
all they have to offer is certain things
right but i personally think that you
know if a person is asking for something
such a sex in that respect
it should be your requirement to offer
and if you're trying to work towards
something higher like in the future you
both have plans to get married why
wouldn't you want to work towards trying
to appease your partner in that respect
so how did we get from
this
back to the board
so so all right class we got a little
off topic but we're going back so this
was actually requested to be brought on
by my producer
um i don't know he knows some wild
people i guess because he asked is
sleeping in the same bed as someone
cheating but you're not doing anything
yes yeah
yeah i don't sleep on the floor listen
if arsenal dm even saying i've got a man
he's cheating now what do you think
being on the ground yeah well we'll just
let's just i just in case there's any
confusion
for both for both yes does a guy get any
props if he sleeps in the same bed as a
girl and doesn't hook up i'm gonna be
real with you yeah like we have slept in
girls beds and we haven't hooked up with
him and i just
i don't know but i know if a girl sleeps
on a guy's bed she's hooking up with him
but if a guy sleeps on the girl's bed
doesn't mean hooking up with her
wow
because women are the gateway to sex
thank you
thank you
hold on hold on hold on hold on listen
a girl will let you sleep in her bed
knowing that you will never because the
only way you can get there is by by
giving it to you right that's what i was
trying to
she will actually let you sleep in your
bed and make you roast and not give you
nothing yeah that's what i'm saying and
even as a friend a girl will let you
sleep on the bed and you know she's your
friend and you will never try because
you know she's a friend but if a girl
says does it the opposite way around
just know it's a wrap she goes in the
guy's bed inside i get your point i get
your point i think i was trying to say
like how can you say that if i go you
just said the same thing switched it out
no because women no because women are
different right i'm being honest with
you right you you could let a man sleep
in your bed and you know you're not
gonna give him nothing right honestly
unless you're not that type of woman
then if you're that type of woman that
does that then it throws it out of the
window right but most women can let a
man sleep in their bed they've let their
friends before at uni or something that
you know i mean little crash and it's
been okay but if if it's the opposite
way around
what no no i'm with you
speaking from a personal experience
i was in a relationship and i was in a
situation where i wasn't allowed to
allowed to come home
that night because of another
circumstance while i was in a
relationship i had a friend he was a
male friend
he offered to let me stay at his inner
for the night it was very circumstantial
on the way back from wherever we were
so i stayed at his and yes i slept in
his bed because i was not sleeping on
the floor in his house i just refused he
never nothing had a couch bathtub
he had a whole house he had no couch he
had no couch
so he slept in the same bed as you yeah
he said to me
i would tell i would tell your boyfriend
to dump
it to me
my little brother had a very similar
situation i said dumper let me just
explain he said to me it's either i
sleep in
his bed or in his mom's bed i said to
him i would rather sleep in your bed
because i know you and you can sleep in
your mom's bed so your boyfriend knew
you had the option of sleeping in his
bed or his mom's bed and you told him
that yeah he knew but then he stepped
into the same bed as you said we both
we topped and tailed it so he had
options oh my god
i'll be honest with you it would have
been it would have made more sense for
him to sleep in his mom's bed because i
can go sleeping
he didn't want to but he wasn't telling
but then you should have gone yeah
i'm not sleeping in your mom's bed
this is a red flag
okay i'm just gonna just to clarify okay
just just here
i don't know but i'm just saying at the
time
hundred percent i have to say that at
the time as well does it as bad as it is
this is you
and that's that red flag
in there at the time bear in mind that
this was a lot of years ago yeah but at
the time i was so in love with my
boyfriend that the concept of this
person who's offering me a place to stay
in his house
him
even like having a but he had intention
yes but in my head and my heart i was so
in love with who i was with at the time
if your boyfriend did that to you would
you be fine with that
if he called you and said listen i'm
going to sleep with this one some girl
in her bed don't worry about me she
could no but i'm not gonna lie of course
not but the difference between me and
him is that i would voice that he didn't
as a man so
i'm in a situation where it's an
emergency situation you know i have
nowhere to say you can't get a hotel
there's no money you can't you can't you
can't just
i'm on my way back from college i'm
saying this was years ago
i was either 17 or 18 at the time so old
enough to get a hotel yeah but not old
enough to understand that and how it's
important
it's the same age as me
babies you understand what i'm saying
situation
that are watching if you're ever in this
scenario do not stay staying i wouldn't
do it now
i wouldn't do it why wouldn't you do it
now because i understand boundaries
but as a child or as a late teenager she
didn't whatever it was
if someone kills someone at 18 are they
responsible
of course they can't say i'm a child
no but it's different because
it's circumstantial
it went like he was just oh yeah like
you know i got a free yard why don't you
come over and stay
i had nowhere to go do you know what i'm
saying i couldn't go to your boyfriend
no
uncle do you know what i'm saying i
couldn't go to his it was just in the
time it was the only place that i felt
like i had to go and i remember even
talking to you at the time
do you get what i'm saying and it was
just at the time i was explaining and
i'm not gonna lie of course i knew how
mad it looked but i explained to the boy
and you know we had our conversation and
even for me at the time i thought the
fact that we're even having this
conversation he already knew how in love
with my boyfriend i was it was just
circumstantial if things can happen but
nothing happened
it comes i think because you're so young
you're 17 you said yeah it comes with
maturity as well you wasn't experiencing
at this age at this age
i can give you the side eye a bit but at
17 18 exactly
you still have the same mindset exactly
18.
joe i think i think if you respect your
man that much you know the boundaries
before he even has a ladybug
18 years old
you've only just started dating yeah i
know and you know full well that you
know not to sleep in another man's bed
when you're in a relationship but she
said they were friends
exactly
but he
at the time was my one of my closest
friends at the time okay he might be he
might be but was he your type
if he was your type and you stepped in
the beds maybe something would have
happened within itself
no honestly that doesn't even matter
within itself because you could have put
in yourself in a situation where i i
understand that's your friend but at the
same time you could have been
overpowered
was your friend right you could have
been overpowered by him at the same time
and at that your boyfriend only has to
take you at your word he doesn't know
that nothing happened for fact because
again that's true that's that's very
true like you're you are the gateway to
sex at the end of the day you can say
that nothing had happened between you
and this man
but right okay that's perfectly fine
that you're saying that but he only can
take you at your word and who is he then
to tell you that i don't accept that you
did this
to him that's disrespectful and so how
do you know the other person your friend
wasn't having feelings no but
for me he was waiting
at the time even if he did or didn't if
even if he was or wasn't plotting for me
it didn't matter because i wasn't
this what i'm saying it's circumstantial
because for me and where my head and
heart was at the time
i didn't like what like well why does
there's so many excuses why didn't you
just say i did some dumb [ __ ]
yeah because it was so good
you were
like for me it was circumstantial and
also i'm not gonna lie like at the time
he was the person that i was with at
that time he was the first and only
person i'd ever been with do you
understand that i know the person when i
say i had no experience with men he was
the first guy so to me
i had look i was i was i was a virgin
most of college and i do like i don't
feel like you could that's an excuse
like you you just know that's true you
know i'll give that to you guys it's not
an excuse and now today no i wouldn't i
would never do that to a person i'm
sleeping with and i wouldn't accept it
from a person i'm sleeping with but i'm
saying it was just in a retaliation to
when
i don't remember your name okay well
this is the china i said yeah this is
the if if a girl goes into a man's bed
if a girl goes into a man's bed then
something is destined to happen and i'm
just saying that from my experience it
wasn't so you can't generalize every
single woman under that umbrella because
it's not the truth because for me when i
was in my circumstance the person that i
was with i was so in love with when i
went into this person's bed my mind
wasn't even in that his place i'm going
through my situation with my family i'm
not even thinking of anything like that
i'm just in this place but i'm sitting
there i'm crying i'm just depressed but
i just have somewhere to sleep that
night i'm not thinking oh cause i'm
going to your bed obviously you didn't
have to sleep in his bed though it was
just happening
one more thing
if you really loved your boyfriend you
could have slept on the floor no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no because i don't want to keep i'm
going to on i'm going to move on okay
okay so next next for everyone at home
having instagram in a relationship
let's say in a marriage let's let's take
it one step further
for a boy to have it is it cheating not
cheating not a public profile i'm not
cheating
all right raise your hand if you think
it's cheating
okay i don't i don't think i don't think
it's cheap
i don't think it's cheating are you are
you are your business or anything are
you just yeah
this is just like
how what percent of people have business
no i'm just i'm just trying to okay i'm
just trying to because yeah i know i
know there's exceptions but yeah we're
talking about the rule all right cool so
if we're dealing with that then then
public profile then it's a red flag it's
not cheating but it's a red flag
because that's the prelude to cheating
being married having a public profile
yeah public yeah
all right second one
for a girl
same thing red flag
not really you know what do you mean
public profile your page is open
yeah like you're open to messages
yeah like drake can dm you all right
cool basically this is something i
believe right
okay what are you willing to do for your
for your husband that you have never
done for another man right and you're
not going to come with virginity because
you're well i'm saying if you're not a
virgin then you're not coming with
with your youth like with you with your
purity right a lot of women are coming
in
a lot of bodies and and a lot of
experience here a lot of trauma right so
you come with all of these things right
so if a man sees you of all of these
things and he says you know what
forget the bodies forget everything
that's gone um forget the age i'm
willing to come and wife you and put a
ring on your finger but the one thing
that i just i require for you is that
once we get married i would appreciate
if you could come off instagram oh this
is coming off instagram i'm going
private or just coming off instagram i'd
appreciate if you come off instagram um
because
you know i don't really want you same
access to people that
you know that could have access to you
prior and this includes all the the the
all your orbiters or your ex guys
drake all these people
just in case you never know no because
drake and floyd mayweather do dm people
average girls and then and they destroy
average guys live they've been seen to
do it you know what i'm trying to say to
you and this is the thing they can at
any moment so
you know
and if your wife isn't willing to do
that then it says to me that she's
holding on to but not everyone uses
instagram for you yeah we just she just
said it's a dating app for dating
do you have a business networking what
type of network um what's happening
network i work in a modeling agent so i
scout for girls well that's a red oh
that's that's basically cheating how's
that cheating working
so basically if you're married and then
you say oh yeah i'm going to keep it
open i'm a moderator that's how i make
money oh man that's how we're going to
feed our kids
no you're not going to feed the kids off
modern and you're going to feed your
kids off the main thing that your
husband does
no i think this is this is not that
comfortable i would never ever ever
depend on a man's money it's not about
dipping yeah it is dependent
when you marry a ma
when you get married it's a two-income
household okay i'll i'll make my money
my partner will make him it's not your
money but a man's money is the family's
money your money is your own well not in
my would it be my household my money
will be the family household money i'll
pay the bills of it he can pay certain
type of bill he'll he'll probably pay
the lights i'll probably pay the
mortgage it's a team here so what do you
want 50 50. i don't mind if you want to
do like a joint bank account like i just
feel like if you're married
i had a joint bank account okay it
doesn't bother me the father my child it
does not bother me
after we split up we
okay so so all right who thinks it's
cheating having ig no no no anyone
anyone think it is for a girl no it's
not cheating but it's a huge red flag
i'll i'll put some red if you're married
one red flag
no
no because the board says the water is
having ig
tia has an ig yeah
anything
she said open public yeah it's a red
flag all right all right okay all right
all right having having tinder
but but
because women go outside they get hit on
every day and then it's not the same so
if a man
why would your mind have a tinder why
are you seeking that yeah like that's
what it's not
i'm just playing devil's advocacy
don't seek that i'm not
posting your holiday pictures on tinder
but put me in there what's the devil's
advocate position with
it's like a woman all right a woman goes
outside we just get hit on we have
people move to us all the time right
where a man he doesn't necessarily get
that he has to do it so if he has a
tinder profile like it's just basically
the attention we get on a daily basis
devil's advocate so the man wants to be
a woman now
you know go outside she's got a lot of
men okay so now next
no not over here
over here does anyone does anyone have
anything else they want to put on the
board or as a question for cheating or
not cheating
having um
okay oh i have a partner friend having
boyfriends as yeah yeah have enough
having having made attention that isn't
your man no i don't think it's not i
don't think it's true no i meant like
opposites
having a close friend that's a male yeah
yes i look for an actually you don't
think that's strange
it's it's it's cheating no it is for me
i think what are you telling what are
you telling this guy that you can't tell
your man no it's
i have a really close friend i can't see
that as a best friend and he's a male is
he guessing do you guys sleep do you
guys sleep in the same bed no you don't
sleep in the same boat
he's not gay i knew him when he was
single when he was a playboy like
nothing happened i watched him grow and
get married and he's got his marriage i
watched him grow and get married
yeah
and i so so now when he's at home do you
call it no i don't i that's that's the
thing i respect his partner and i
understand and i understand someone and
i understand he has a family so i won't
call him at a pacific time i won't call
him let's say let's say past seven
o'clock or something because he's got a
daughter now situations do change but
the love and the friendship that i have
with him so one of the last things
about your friend
today today okay
so so panel handle this situation right
here
she gets she gets married yeah
is she cheating or not cheating all
right raise your hand
raise your hand
hands we like hands here
i'm sorry cheater cheaters
what about him is he cheating in this
situation
even more more than more than the female
it works both ways someone is always
compensating someone is always
compensated but someone is always when a
woman can't be friends with you
put the other person in the friend zone
this is how it works men and women can't
be friends in it yeah i'm only friends
with girls because i don't have an
attraction to them or
exactly
he doesn't have an attraction to me i
don't have an attraction to him but if
we if we had that we would have been no
no but
years ago from school no but i'm saying
it's never happened
i i want to ask guys guys have you ever
been friends with a girl for years never
hooked up with her but
you would 100 percent facts yeah yeah
okay that's like ninety percent
you know what yeah your best friend that
you think is your male friend yeah just
message him and say oh you know what i
just broke up with my man you know i'm
just feeling really low oh will you call
him right now
we'll test it we'll test it
do it do it do it do it sticky
it's it's late you're not gonna have
that by the end of this but what time is
it and then and then you can you can
show them the stream after so it'll save
the friendship you know
like this host just kept pressuring me
you know first of all it's inappropriate
because it's late and he's got a
new baby he's got a one-year-old that's
the whole point like it's an
inappropriate call where's my phone i
don't even have my phone here
but you need to you need to tell him
what we're telling you to sell him say
no but he might say
something all you've got to do is say to
him listen i'm feeling really lonely i'm
feeling really low like i know i've
spoke to you like this before but i just
really want you no he's not married
don't create no i wouldn't i wouldn't
there wouldn't be a problem with if he's
loyal and he's your friend
does it matter see this is the thing so
you already know he's not your friend
because you don't even want to create a
scenario
i don't want to put someone into that
situation
i can't be friends no no i don't know
i don't want to put someone into that
situation where
how can you put him into something where
if he's gonna say no he's gonna say no
calling him he's your brother huh he's
your brother
what are you doing
i've never i've known before i've known
him for a very long time
if something could have happened it
would happen years ago so he's not
attracted to me
does anyone else have a male friend they
want to test downstream anyone no
i think it's okay what about what about
you
the bed sleeper
i don't keep male friends personally i
don't i'm a big believer that mellows
and females can't be friends because she
knows i know no i know i know men
personally i feel like it's they can't
come they can't do it without intentions
okay you know just for that just for
that
that's what i'm not trust me i've
learned from myself
thank you thank you my partner can have
female friends i wouldn't care i'm not a
jealous person
and vice versa has nothing to do
if you loved your partner and you valued
him you would understand that and he's a
man of value these people are gonna see
what i've got and they're gonna throw it
at my man you like you're trusting these
girls because you gotta remember there's
not enough of these men around so if you
really got yourself a catch and they
know he's got a catch they're going to
take that catch from you you're not mad
literally you're not married so he's not
yours
i would never ever have an issue with my
partner having female friends that's
just me no but i'm not saying that i'm
saying he's not he's not married
i would never have it i would never have
he's not married if i met you today yeah
see the way i look at it if a woman
hasn't got a ring on her finger she's
fair game and the reason it is is you've
had previous previous relationships
before that was like i've got a man i've
got a man you're not with them anymore
because you didn't have a ring on it
they just previously relationship so
unless a girl has got a ring and a
finger i know already i can i can i can
i can i can affect this you know why
because if your man really wanted you he
would have married you he doesn't want
you because he hasn't married you and
this is the truth for the matter men
know what we want and when we see
something that we want we lock it down
that's why when we're outside and we see
a good girl there's not a lot of good
girls there's a lot of girls you can
sleep with take out post on the gram
look good you know what i'm trying to
say to you but there's not many girls
you can bring home when you find one one
two three four guys are all competing
for that one girl because there's not
that many but when it comes to sleeping
around we can get that from anywhere
that's all i'm trying to say so when it
comes down to men and
me personally i wouldn't keep a pretty
woman like you like you're a pretty girl
i can't see how he's his wifey must be
even prettier to be like you know what
yeah she's beautiful
to be that confident but then again
no do you know what i'm saying
that's true it's like i'm okay with the
friends as long as they're ugly
oh yeah
that's what it wouldn't be then you
realize you gotta worry about the ugly
girls too
he might
not it's always the ugly girls because
the moment you draw personality you drop
do you do something wrong it's the
personality it's the oh i wouldn't do
that to you yeah
they're just they're they're like
really quick before it before i sit back
down anyone else have anything they want
to add to the board
[Music]
what about
um a man or a uh like if you have a man
or girl that's with like the nightlife
good questions
have you seen girls on holidays
where
arms are linked don't touch my friend
okay so i
caveat okay
so
what about a bachelorette party cheating
no no no no no no no no no
yeah
because you can do that right but you
the one thing i don't want to see is my
my girlfriend that's in the relationship
outside with a bunch of single girls
because as especially if your girls are
pretty and you're pretty gang you know
what i'm trying to say to you if you're
one of them girls you're going gonna go
outside you're gonna get attention now
if my girl is out with two other friends
or three other friends and there's four
of them or five of them and she's in a
relationship and they're out and you
know they're getting male attention
that's fine they're allowed to get that
but now my my girl's in the vicinity of
this in it and we don't want this and a
lot of guys a lot of times women will
say oh no that's controlling but this is
what we created to you like we treat a
woman you're a high value woman you we
treat you like as a bugatti let's say
your mom will get you right the most
expensive because i'm going to compare
you to bugatti well you know yeah we're
going to pay you to begat you so the
most expensive car in the world right
like i'm not gonna park my bugatti in
for example
um
hack me or something in the ghetto park
at the end we like happening but i'll
i'm not gonna do that even though that
my car's got the best safety in the
world even though it even though that no
one can get into it i'm gonna risk that
you know i want to risk that because
someone can still try to scratch my
bugatti someone cause who's had to break
the window my bugatti in actual fact you
might meet the best coffee from the
world and they might actually get away
with the bugatti and that's how i
consider stuff to be so why would you
want your woman in any place where she
could put herself or someone could
scratch her someone could steal her so
okay so just to paraphrase cheating yes
no pearl i wouldn't say okay so for the
for the boys going clubbing cheating yes
or no no no no yeah yes 100 okay wait
raise your hand if you think it's
cheating for a man to go clubbing well
in a regular place it's just one yeah it
just depends how like not like club it
like i don't i don't really know what
the london clubs are but like
is there is there a big club in london
yes
whatever the big club in london is
oh it's ish that's the name oh no it's
the mayfair oh mayfair okay he's going
to mayfair
is he cheating
every week
yeah let's let's say let's let's crank
it up this is what i said if this if if
i was a man no i need a yes or no from
everyone no cheating no it's not cheesy
okay so now you can go
no that's what the whole board is
basically well the way i'm looking at is
because
i'm with my girl now and i know she's a
she's good to me she's a good girl so i
would let her go clubbing i'll let her
have instagram because i put my trust in
her and i say to her all the time you
can do all of this but if i see anything
dodgy don't come back crying when i say
it's over but that's me putting my trust
in her because i know that she's a
beautiful girl she's going to get loads
of attention and you see i i feel like
when you're with a guy like you like you
don't really want to do that i feel like
that's the difference between like
just like if i'm with you what am i
going to the club for you
i think i think going clubbing is it's
actually a good thing
it's nice
for a birthday then it's funny birthday
friend's birthday it's like exactly
let's give your mental health as well
it's good for your mental health
when i say mental health it's nice to go
out have fun let your hair do i'm a
mother yeah i've got a nine-year-old
daughter
and for me letting myself loose going
out with my girls going to a bar or a
club once in a while i'm not talking i'm
not saying every weekend yeah that's
difficult
bottom line i'm still a mother
but um once in a while i've got my girls
have a good time have a drink there's no
problem
why don't you go to applebee's do you
guys have applebee's here like you can
just go go out to dinner with your
friends yeah and like have a nice dinner
a thousand balls in london there's
always places to go
i feel like sometimes it's an energy
thing though like for example this
summer i was quite down and then
carnival came and it was just yeah
i saw what happened at carnival that's a
motive she's referring to clubbing are
you i'm not i'm just saying that what
i'm referring to what she was saying
she's saying you're saying that it's a
vibe like it's a it's a yeah sometimes
it's just an energy thing like yeah you
can feel it wow but the board is saying
clubbing i know you got it i know i know
we know that i'm just referring to what
she's saying which she was saying that
yeah everyone needs a once in a while
for me
i don't i don't like what do i gotta go
to a podium
do i want my mom going to the club
that's worse that's worse i think my
godmother lives on our heels every week
if my mom went clubbing i'd be like
enjoy yourself she doesn't know she does
that
i would be embarrassed if my mom went
clubbing that would be embarrassing to
me and this is the thing like like it's
crazy because the fact that you're
honest you don't understand that when
you're in a relationship you need to do
some things that you didn't do when you
when you were singing like do things you
didn't do when you're single right so
it's like
you cannot be outside the same way you
was because when i see girls outside
then they say i got a man for i'm like
what are you doing outside i actually
always say to like where's your man uh
and then you put yourself in a scenario
where you can continuously have you ever
heard when they say oh i was drunk oh
yeah oh i didn't mean to do that that's
never happened in a sober thing when
someone was outside the applebee's for
example it always happens when you put
yourself in places where the alcohol
when there's drugs where there's all
these types of things then you made a
mistake you cannot make a mistake when
you're coherent when you're not around
certain things because you think a
woman's only much better for just
staying at home constantly
that's not the point i don't think
that's the point at all i think the
point is why as a woman when you have
these responsibilities why would you go
and put yourself in a situation where
other men are going to look at you and
want to take you home for a second
that's the point when it talks about how
you could go to nando's you literally
could go to nando's and have fun with
your guys is fire
yeah we don't really got it in the u.s
like that
but i understand that you want to go
have fun you don't actually have to go
out to a place where there's loads of
men but i
yeah i generally think it's how you
conduct yourself how you portray
yourself i can go out i might go maybe i
might go carnival but i'm not leaving
any numbers
it's like you're going to a bunch of
potential okay you're a car right like
this is an analogy i know women aren't
cars this is always the first thing but
it's like it's like you're going to the
dealership where there's potential
buyers and saying i'm for sale and just
because you didn't sell out you're
saying oh well you're easily manipulated
if you don't sell out yeah but you still
went to the dealership where men are
buying no
going club listen go to a bar or club or
whatever even carnival you want to
listen to good music you want to be
around your girls you want to have a
drink you want to listen i mean there's
nothing wrong with that
it's only an issue when you make it
friday saturday sunday tuesday
that's a problem that i'm going to look
at my partner is like what's up
in this context yeah there's you're
referring to that as your vote so what
you're not understanding is that it's
her advice that that's the same thing as
me choosing to go to pottery every week
when there's mandate there as well i
don't think it's the same thing no one's
looking for sexual gratification from
you for a possibility yeah
i have a question for the boys do you go
to a pottery class to get laid no no do
you go to a club to get laid that is
just
stop interrupting me do you go to
carnival to get laid
so no so basically
i
i i got to ask you because i went i went
carnival my girl in it so i went
carnival so but
you got a man did you go carnival with
your man
no red flag
hold on hold on
what
do you realize yeah
just by having my girl like two steps
away from me do you know what i asked my
partner do you want to go carnival he
said no that's not his style i said okay
i'm gonna go i want to go carnival so
there was a communication there that's
it like i asked him he said no he didn't
want to go i would be happy to go what
did you give wines out huh did you give
any wines out me yeah no i would i did
not no i'm just asking because some
people don't know but i don't go do you
pick it wait i'll go carnival for the
culture
don't climb my head oh i'm going to go
carnival okay to go and meet me okay i
get it i get it what'd you say it's
catching on giving a wine you know
carnival what's the wine what's a wine
dirty dance you know the dogs
no i was doing interviews i didn't
really oh is that the twerking thing
they be like yeah so when they're like
the girls
but you see me you see me like to me
that's cheating the people at carnival
say no it's culture i'll be like that's
not like for me okay i'll add that up
that's inappropriate because i wouldn't
want my i wouldn't want my significant
other partner or anyone to be dancing
how many men move to you please just be
honest don't cat just be honest how many
men approach should be honest bear man
right yeah but did she entertain him
but the fact that you even put yourself
in that you know you know
carnival is a celebrity if you're from
the caribbean it's a celebrity
[Music]
can i just say something right my
grandma was born in 1938 she absolutely
just is disgusted by the idea that at
carnival you twerk and and and that's
how we celebrate jamaican culture she's
absolutely sickened by it that's not
what it means to be jamaican and i'd
like to say that as a fact right now
it's not what it means to be jamaican
and the fact that that's what's being
permeated from jamaican culture quite
frankly is a disgrace
yes okay so clubbing for girls cheating
not cheating yes or no let's get a yeah
it's a red flag but it's not cheap if
they go out with their girls for a
girl's birthday then it's fine it's
they're going on there's caveats there's
caveats there's caveats to this
scenario she's doing it every weekend no
it's a red flag
she's getting popped off yeah yeah
every weekend yes every week she's
cheating okay
girls trip boys trip cheating not
cheating girl strip cheating
have you been to a girl's trip okay
let's
go on one with my boyfriend i'll be
honest with you i would i would not go
on one i would want to go with my
boyfriend i don't see why i would go on
just some major girls trips to some
the where's the foreign depends where
the trip is okay
i feel like there's two types of girls
trips there's one type where you go
like i think my parents we have a house
in florida and you go to someone's beach
maybe this is just
like where i'm from thing but you go to
someone's beach house and you hang out
with the girls but you don't really
leave the beach house but then there's
number two will you go to miami
you go to vegas
yeah so nashville yeah so the first one
that's not cheap that's something that
girls do when they do a retreat i think
yeah i think women need to do those
types of things those are like i think
in all movies all growing up women need
to do those types of things yeah so we
need that we need them to go out and
have
that yeah is not a red flag we actually
need women to actually meet up with the
girls and go and do these types of stuff
we need that for them yeah okay so but
the second one but what we don't need is
our girls out in miami twerk yeah yeah
we're doing in places getting moved by
chad and tyrone that's not what we need
out here bro that's not what we need
so what about for a boy is the boys a
boy's trip cheating
he's vice versa
what he just said the other way around
no men and women are not the same no
what he just said the other way around
you can do your little male retreats
that's fine no but no we don't do
retreats we don't do that
i mean look at look at okay devil's
advocate here my brothers don't do boys
trip they go hunting they go fishing
they go they go
that's real manly bonding like
they're gonna kill some deer yeah that's
but that's different that's some real
stuff like you want to do that you know
what i mean like we don't have that's
some stuff that we would like
no like what they'll do is they'll go to
like they're like a rural wisconsin
they'll get drunk with their boys and
then they'll go shoot some deer
yeah but that's not they're not they're
not about to go start twerking on some
deal
yeah but like if you go to a club the
girls are gonna start twerking on you
so like wouldn't it be cheating
i wouldn't say cheating no because we
went to go shoot deal
what
no because i i said you could do that
one that could be like the equivalent of
going to that girl's house like the
beach house yeah yeah and like that's
that's option one and then there's
option two which is like clubbing
so you wouldn't say clubbing is cheating
on some level yeah i'd be so embarrassed
if my dad was going clubbing i'd be so
embarrassed
but i also don't it goes both ways to me
i think and i'll be honest as well like
men
when you most of them men that i know
that that get in serious relationships
they don't really tend to be outside
like that you have to pull them outside
they don't really want to come outside
yeah
when men are more likely to when we get
in a relationship because you've got to
remember every time we go outside for
some of us it costs us 500 pounds every
time we go outside yeah for the men that
and that's the minimum like we're
talking like pearl we're talking about
men outfit going out and buying the
table doing all these things the moment
you get a girlfriend and a wife
everything becomes cheaper for you so
you're not about to get a wife and then
be outside again because now you're
still having to buy drips still having
to buy tables and now you're buying
tables for girls to sit down which you
have not to drink it no it doesn't make
any sense it's a bad investment
having a wife for you long term is
actually a lot cheaper than going
outside and trying to find all these
girls every week and taking taking five
separate girls out in the space of a
month you do the math mathematically
yeah
so cheating no
i put not and yet like forever i think
it's the same thing all right twerking
last this is the last one so i want to
sit down um twerking cheating or not
cheating cheating so
amanda beats working so for a man let's
say he's at carnival he's watching the
girl twerk he's like
you know they were doing the clap i
don't know i don't think it's cheating i
just think it's inappropriate like i
don't think he's cheating no do you
wind up with a girl for 12 you get
excited i think it's inappropriate
i got excited um no she's twerking on
him i think it's just inappropriate i
don't think it's cheating i just think
it's inappropriate
cheating now no it's not cheating
it's just a red flag you catch wines and
move on okay you see all right chat if
anyone needed help in their relationship
you're welcome
for the white board
good job class
i feel like the white ball is going to
be coming out a lot a lot now
i do feel like i was a teacher in
another life i don't know
i feel like most of the questions on the
whiteboard all solely depends on the
girl that you're with exactly most of
those things i let my girl do but i
because i trust her
if you do not let your girl go clubbing
on her girl's birthday if you do not let
your girl have instagram that you do not
trust her and you cannot be with her no
bro you can't say that no no no no no
bro listen you gotta understand yeah
girls girls that girls get attention
everywhere but it all depends if they
entertain it
all depends on that no but listen the
fact that she's got the instagram she's
already entertaining it and the likes
because she poses she's posting bikini
pictures then yeah no like the fact that
listen if it didn't matter she would get
rid of it and i'm not saying for her to
get rid of it like i said like i said
again she's your girlfriend now if you
say you want to make into your wife here
do you really want the whole world and
everybody previously that access to
torah to still have access to her is
that something well i'm not i'm not
gonna lie personally with my when
when i'm with my bird she had her
profile private
beautiful woman yeah to me anyways
i told her to take her profile private
because attention is currency right now
she took her profile private within one
month some guy in boxed her sent her
filters they take pictures we'll send
you three hundred pound every two weeks
she said they sent her three on japan
over two weeks and me and her go ahead
eating that but this is this what
but this is what i'm trying to tell you
she doesn't entertain it as that but you
can use it as a girls use it as a
currency attention is currently right
now okay so let me select so long as
you're not doing it in a flirty way
where you're like yeah sexy
long as you straight business because
girls can use instagram and social media
yeah but as a dude is it your job to
protect and provide
so like why are you trying to make money
off your instagram no i'm not trying to
make no i'm not a girl i'm not trying to
make money off instagram i'm saying if
you if you have instagram don't put
bikini pictures on maybe use it for you
know modeling or taking selfies use it
for something more decency
what's being done with the pictures if
you don't mind me asking there's no
bikini pictures there's no nothing
it's always she's got a pretty face
she's got a pretty face it's all it's
all she does is takes a picture of her
face and he puts a filter oh and that's
it this is sad and i can't lie bro like
like like
this is not levels of
basically only fans it's it's it's not
the same but basically what you're
saying is you really wouldn't mind your
woman setting up a only pattern because
as long as men pay for it and it's just
just the face is okay but you should be
providing that level where no man can
offer free bills where she's going to
take and you shouldn't be taking that
free bill no i think no man should turn
down 300 pounds yeah
okay like i've been offered money for
feet picks and i turned it down because
i don't know what they're going to do
with it that's weird
and it's like it's like if my i always
this is how i always think about it i'm
like all right if my mom was doing this
how would i feel if my mom was saying
pics i would be embarrassed but that's
feet pics pearl we're talking about a
selfie
and then that's it
yeah but some yeah i would say selfies
i think it comes down to insecure as
long as she's not flirting no no
anything like that i don't think it
comes down to responsibility i don't i
don't think it's insecurity it's just
wanting to protect what's yours and you
don't know what type of situation you
can be put in
like you don't you don't know she she
doesn't open instagram drake could dmr
yeah exactly but this is what i'm trying
to say to you
drake could dmo rip away if she if she
entertains it that's where the line
grows
but why would you put her in that
situation to start like what did it like
because as women we look to men for
leadership so like like i would respect
a guy more if he says like i don't think
it's a good idea for our relationship
yeah but how do you depend on it it
depends
how did you meet her because if you met
her she had an earthquake instagram and
she was this person why are you gonna
now come in and change her
because listen yeah okay we're talking
about i'm taking you seriously now yeah
you've been outside now and now i'm
taking you seriously right and i want to
make you into my long-term woman into my
wife
what are you gonna do for me that you
haven't done for another man you're not
bringing me your purity you're not
bringing me your your youth depending on
when you're coming so
and if you're coming with baggage and
other other stuff the one thing i ask is
look babe look just to do a clean start
we're gonna start our life we're gonna
move in with me we're gonna go here can
we just leave that old life behind us
and you cannot get rid of it it says to
me you want to be outside because at
some point you are not ready to go into
the new life you're still holding on to
and what is so good about instagram
you've got a man that's willing to take
you down the aisle willing to move in
with you give your life and you want the
gram but it's but it's it is
circumstantial though because
the way that some of us use instagram is
different to the way that other because
i'm if you say
delete it because i don't want to give
you a problem i don't want to make you
want to um
like to stop feeling like you're
controlling me but
i go on for memes and funniness and to
keep up that's where i get my views but
you could just do it like a profile with
no pictures yeah an account
yeah exactly that's what i'm saying i
would never mind go put my instagram on
private yeah for my partner what about
deleting it no i wouldn't delete it why
because that's
i promote art i don't have an answer i
just wouldn't delete it the answer is
it's just that you're not willing to
really commit and you're not really
trusting the leadership of your partner
because if you did your man will be
enough for you i don't know what the
love affair with instagram is that when
you've got someone that's willing to
stop give your whole life and look
imagine this right you're not with the
um
the father of your of your daughter
right so you meet a new man and you
already
you already know how it
how it is you know being a single single
mother and dating and whatever you know
so you've got a man that's wants to
marry you he wants to be a stepfather to
your child and the one the one thing
he's put down is that i just want you to
get rid of the gram and you say no
yeah
do you do you think how likely do you
think you wait
a man that wants to be a stepfather and
you know none of us want to be
stepfathers we're not russian we're not
what me personally i don't i don't date
women with kids i just it's not not
something i would do um
like yeah instagram clearly no yeah no i
could date with instagram but i'm not
gonna marry a woman that has an
instagram open to the public when i'm
ready to marry her and do all these
things that are whatever when it's open
to the pr that's not an issue
but either i don't think it's i think
my sister she has instagram and she's
she puts quotes about the bible
like do i mean influential there's
nothing nothing wrong with that it's
what you use instagram for i i've had
people contact me on instagram that i
met in reception year one is do i mean
like people i don't know it's a nice way
to get so instagram for you is like
facebook for other people like i would i
would delete instagram but i wouldn't
delete facebook because facebook is how
i keep his contacts yeah but it's like
those people aren't real
like how many people do you really deal
with in day-to-day life like my dad's in
the top one half a percent of earners
and he doesn't have any social media you
don't need it and it makes you think you
have these like connections and that
like you're talking to people you really
don't the only person that matters is
your man and your family i don't
understand how a man can be willing to
be willing to marry you
and this is what i'm trying to say about
why it's not worth becoming a stepfather
because i'm dating with children because
you don't even understand what he's
doing you don't actually understand
you're treating him like he's any of a
guy he's willing to get married to you
become a stepfather so i'm saying to you
and you're still and he only asks for
you to come off the ground but you can't
because they're like i come off the
ground for myself no no no no no no no
when it comes to stepfather trust me as
a mother myself we it doesn't like
we're not we don't care about that
aspect no but what i'm trying to say to
you is any man by default becomes a
stepfather so for example if a man
starts dating you right yeah and he
becomes serious about you right yeah
automatically he's a stepfather because
when he wants to come and do something
with you he has to facilitate your
daughter so example if he wants to buy a
house right yeah he if it's just you and
him he could buy a one bedroom or two
bedroom home right but when he has you
and your daughter he's gonna think well
i need to get a three bedroom home
because we have to have a child so
automatically he's always gonna have to
do it so if you and him have a child
right and then um
um he um your child wants to go to um
what wants to go on holiday and each one
wants to go on holiday but he said you
know what
he's going to send his child to to
america and because he's your child he's
going to send your child to cornwall are
you going to be happy about that if
they're out if they're out at carnival
let's say for example and then he's got
your child out with his daughter and
he's got his child but his daughter's
your daughter says she wants an an ice
pole or something he's like now call
your dad and pay for it are you going to
be happy about that
because what i'm trying to make you
understand is when a man dates you he's
always going to be a stepfather in some
way whether or not he's financially or
whether or not it's just by being there
you might not classify as a step forward
but the moment he's having to use his
resources his time his money on the
child that isn't his he's a stepfather
how do we get if i if
the whole point he's making is like like
relationships are about compromise and
so and so and so if he's willing to step
into that role which is really hard for
men to do because they're
predispositioned to be disgusted by
other people's children the least you
could do is delete your instruments as a
mother i don't i wouldn't feel
comfortable in letting any man in my
life not yes the father is making a
sacrifice but as a mother myself
it's hard for us to just let a man in
our house and bring a man to our house
holding it right so we're making i feel
like as parent as a mother we'll make
him more of a sacrifice because we're
letting this man mm-hmm
around our children
but this is like
yeah
but then you should have worked it out
with the person you made a child but but
i'm saying i'm saying like like that's
just that's just i mean i don't i don't
know your situation i don't know you
personally but i'm saying like like
that's just part of it and it's more for
a man to take on a woman's kids because
they're predispositioned to be disgusted
by your children because because
historically they never wanted to pass
on resources to a kid that was not
theirs where you if he has a kid
it's a sign of pre-selection so that
says the other woman chose him we're
attracted to that and so it's just not a
fair deal and so when he has to take an
unfair deal where he has to take on
another band's kid it's like the least
you can do is just delete your social
media
may i just say may i just say that my
father had to do that he he tried to
remarry a woman um who had a child
before she came to him and one thing
that he always said to me of the phone
is
absolutely
it's a great thing to be a father but
being a stepfather is a job that is
thankless with no profit it's a job that
has no profit in return
okay i mean i like that i like that i'm
going to read it i'm going to read super
i don't know
what you don't you don't like the way he
thinks about that listen listen listen
this is the thing
actually you know what yeah what don't
you like huh the instagram bit
the instagram bit doesn't bother me the
instagram it's just your thinking of
step father no man wants to be me coming
into a relationship right now my partner
had a two daughters yeah it did not
affect me one bit actually women don't
care no no let me i actually embraced it
i looked at it as oh that would be nice
for so and so she has chris my
daughter's the only child she's like
she's 10 years old so my mindset is i'm
always looking at the benefit in that
situation i don't look at it like oh i'm
doing this child the so-and-so a favor
because i shouldn't have to be here
because i can find another woman that's
but that's
but that's but that's a woman's point of
view so you're looking at it from a
woman's point of view right but that's
because we're attracted to a man that
can take care of other kids because one
it says to us that oh another girl
selected him that's pre-selection and
the second thing is it says oh he's
going to stick around for my kid but
with a woman it signals to him that
you're promiscuous and that you don't
make sound decisions because you didn't
get married before you had the kid and
then it's it's like less incentive
because why would he marry you if you
didn't marry the first guy and then i
don't have to ask what does your baby
father do i'm not going to ask you
personally but i'm just saying so and
you know it's like like a lot of times
when people are they their baby father
is a waste man they won't like their
baby father talk badly but i think then
i'll look at myself and i'm like damn
actually thought you was nice and all of
a sudden when i see who they chose to to
to breed with i'm like no actually no
you you're looking like a waist girl
because i was rating you i had you on a
pedestal you know most girls i put on a
pedestal and they didn't realize they
were actually on a pedestal then you
look at the choices they made you're
like damn is that what you chose it's
something else that i've heard from
other men why would other men have said
to me why would i want to raise another
man's inferior dna if you chose this man
to if you chose this manner you're
saying he's such a race man right why
would i want to come into this situation
and raise dna that i now will consider
in inferior because you're telling me
how much for a woman oh let me do an
extreme one i know it's like slightly
extreme but i want to use it as
something and let's say i love a child i
bring this child as my own like i raise
this child this child gets really old
and the child gets sick
the child needs a blood transfusion the
kidney i i'm the father's child he calls
me his father the child looks at me as
the dad but at this moment i cannot save
my child at this moment we need to find
a real dad and in this moment i realized
that all this time i've just been
playing and acting like it let's let's
let's flip it around now i'm sick i'm
dying now yeah and this child i've
raised now loves me as a father he's
watching me die he wants to give me
something he can't give me nothing at
that point you realize that whole thing
everything you did was a waste of time
and i'm not trying to but i'm trying to
show you the extreme of you might need
to give your child something in the
future and you cannot do it men are not
supposed to be coming and doing
something else and
you gave the highest honor to another
man and now you're out here be like you
know what i'm a single mother it doesn't
affect me it does affect you i never
said i was a single mother no
no but are you married huh
i've never been in a relationship well
very long but you're still a single
unless you're married you're a single
mother like essentially i don't i don't
consider myself
yes technically i'm a single person but
i've never considered myself
as a single mother at the point you
broke off the stigma behind single
mother for me it's just
and this is the problem right we we get
told as men that having a standard i'm
now being told i'm bad for having a
standard for not actually wanting to
have a single mother like there's
nothing wrong with you as a person
you're actually a cool person but the
fact remains yeah the type of woman i
want is a woman especially if you are
single i would have hoped you got
married is your husband did he die what
really happened was you an abuse if it
was just the fact that i picked the
wrong guy and i
and i bred from him do you know how in
my mind i just think to myself that is
such bad decision making because you
didn't even require a ring you just let
any man literally bust in there and say
yo this is what it is do you have any
kids i don't have no kids no yeah it's
when you have kids it's easy
your mind
hold on a second you're making excuses
i'm 38 years old if i want kids i can
have kids you know what i'm trying to
say to you the reason i don't have kids
i already said i come from a family of
five and my my three sisters and brother
all married we come from unity the
reason i'm not married pearl is because
i keep meeting women that are
problematic that are not ready for this
so it's quite easy i'll realize within
three months or six months whether or
not i want to be with one woman for the
rest of my life because i've been out
here long enough to know and i know
patterns of behavior so when i said i
met a sweet one i was generally meaning
like yo like i've met something that i
feel like god's you know blessing man at
the moment but the only reason i'm not
married well not because i don't want to
not because i'm not a high earning man
not because i'm not worth six fig i'm
six foot not because i'm not doing all
these things it's because women
are too
all the types of women i were meeting
felt like because they earned a certain
thing because they looked a certain way
it gave them certain type of thing but
also what they didn't realize is us as
men we choose so unless you we go in one
ring we go down on one knee and give you
the ring unless you're about to get down
on your knee and buy me a gold rolex you
need to fall back and at the position of
a woman and let me do what am i supposed
to do and then we can get on and get out
of here
but i don't understand how you said it's
because he doesn't have children oh
because i know someone my son's dead um
he said
basically uh like before obviously i had
my son as i would never get with a woman
with a child like oh that's bizarre i
would never do it had a child end up
getting with a woman with a child yeah
because it's family you once you've had
a child
i think more people yeah people i think
people with kids should date each other
like i'm not trying to date a guy with
kids either but not but the point is
it's more it's more it's harder for a
man to accept another per another guy's
kids than it is for a woman to accept
another woman's kids i agree with that
yeah and and so what i'm saying is it's
not it's not a fair deal i think maybe
i'm the masculine one then but i
couldn't i wouldn't bother me but i i
agree what you're trying to say yeah
okay i'm gonna read super chats um
again these are what i'm paid to say
okay
um okay so the uk economist as a
business owner i would never allow a
child that's not mine to inherit my
wealth also only my bloodline will
inherit my success and assets mgtow by
logic modern liberated independent boss
babes are cancer to the contentment of a
man period mgtow by logic also no women
are capable of actual real honest
conversations that's why they get ran
through by chad and tyrone entirely
predictable npc like a fish in a barrel
thanks for the free kitty ladies
um what why just something
this guy has a long name box sorry um hi
pearl how can i get in touch with eddie
other than instagram i don't use social
media even though i created instagram
and messaged him two times now sometimes
my messages disappear this man who is
essentially oh and then the second one
this man who is essentially pimping his
girls on instagram um i'm not gonna lie
to you the only way to get in touch with
eddie is instagram and the best way to
get on the show is to bring girls with
you um as a guy like we have a ton of
guys that want to come on the show like
it's just endless um and it's harder to
recruit women so the best way you can
get on the show is to tell eddie that
you're bringing two girls um jamal allen
pearl please tell the ninja in the red
that red carnival is from trinidad not
jamaica it's a cultural thing that only
people from the caribbean will get you
don't like it don't go
young lex carney isn't jamaican culture
y'all are just invited um christopher
cerdec
um
the can any of these women other than
the massacre pearl remember any
conversation ever where they weren't
lying such cap mgtow by logic 50 super
chat let's go
um funny how these girls are creeping
not me it's amazing this is an awful-ish
this the world is awash in good girls us
men are just so lucky to have these
loyal feminine wives to choose from
um adam sutton hoody dude is so
aggressive chill 90 free topay we judge
others by their actions we judge
ourselves by our intentions unknown
the large delicious queen means well but
as but is a kid get your own room um
phil
siddik thank you for the super chat
henry lucy to the gentleman in the pink
dating apps are now a permanent fixture
and are here to stay it is statistically
the primary method of meeting a
potential mate and instagram is also the
de facto dating app mad dog lambert
thank you for the super chat the bloody
talker dude says guys who use dating
apps are for the streets um then he
realizes he hooks up with insta chick
the back pedaling to not include himself
was impressive but he is for the streets
um musa jamal these guys need to read
the rational mail by rolo tomasi matt
butcher guys get your approach game on
point this will put you ahead of the
miles long of blokes on her apps forget
the apps um chessy me life is great for
me and my husband we met on meet me in
2016 and we're still together to this
day kfc sac women only remember
compliments from chad and tyrone
kerwin thompson bird with a weave was
talking about eurocentric crap gu i'm
just saying
just saying because it's funny to me but
us brazilians actually go to the gym for
a bigger butt so a genuine bbl would be
for a fit girl being healthy matt
butcher let's start a rumor ish landed
18 year old philippine virgin from the
millionaire and is living happily ever
after um most in 1938 i rarely watch you
live usually at 2x speed uh feels like
i'm watching you guys after you've
passed around a doobie what's a doobie
[Laughter]
um i think that's all the super chats
let me refresh them really quick also
guys the number one metric that youtube
uses to push out my content is like look
it i know not everyone since can super
chat a lot of you watching on here
you've been watching for months and you
don't even like my videos like the
audacity so like it a like is free it
takes literally two seconds um also
subscribe to the channel we're trying to
get to half a million by the end of the
year so make sure you subscribe to the
channel
um
90 free topaz how did you get young ma
on your channel the uk economist oh i
already read that one okay
so
um
my next question
why are you laughing no
who did he refer to as young emmy
i don't know it doesn't say i just read
them
okay so so question for everyone here
um
does anyone have any any peace they want
to speak to the super chats now it's
your time
okay yeah i know i want to say something
yeah
yeah yeah because i don't understand if
it's not it's not pimping it out
if she's sent if she's got a face and i
don't understand what
it's like
it's low-level pimping it's not
literally you're telling me if your girl
has got instagram yeah and some guy is
willing to pay 300 pounds for a face
pick no nobody no nothing
for a face picture
you're telling me that's pimping out
yeah
oh okay all right then maybe i'm wrong
but i don't know any i think it's just i
don't know why who's gonna turn down for
you i mean i i would just say it's like
it's like low level but i mean i mean
i mean i mean to be to be fair to be
fair andrew tay did it to me
okay okay okay
okay yeah
he's triggered before we go down that
road triggers
okay so you guys are arguing about body
count why before the show
so yeah they they came in and apparently
i wasn't here for this conversation but
the guests wait in the lobby before they
come up because you know we don't want
to be going up and down it's a long
elevator ride and
then i guess in the lobby there was a
conversation about body count that was
had
so what did i miss fill me in i missed
it so
no um
he's basically saying that what was he
saying it was just waffles simple body
count matters and you don't believe it
does i never said that i don't believe
you okay you was playing there were
there was a yeah exactly
so what was you saying so the reason
body count matters is because i didn't
realize especially poland i'll probably
watch a lot of your content and i spoke
to a lot of other girls that it was that
side
no
um yeah that that this many girls like
were like oh body count doesn't matter
because i was like as far as we knew
body count always matters to us men and
i don't know if you ever didn't have a
mum that didn't love you or dad wasn't
around or you didn't have any brothers
because if you did you would have known
that that that that is is precious that
is sacred and the moment you start
giving it out and the moment you start
doing that it cheapens your values so
the fact that girls think that and and
another thing i always say is like when
you ask a girl
what's her body count
she's gonna lie or she's gonna tell you
the truth once and then when she says it
to a guy that she really likes and he
doesn't like what he is and he
disappears from that moment on she's
going to start lying
what do you guys think
my thing is yeah i do i understand your
point where you say oh buddy does matter
yeah that's fair enough
but
why do you want to know
what
what okay so let's say for instance you
made a good body council all right come
on let's go you meet a body cat um a
girl and a body count is like say six or
something or even ten why does that now
why does that affect
your potential obviously you're saying
that you know there's those ghosts of
christmas past and men's past yeah that
stuff
but
comparison is a thief of joy right so
like initially
initially for us what we wanted we
wanted the virgin so what for in reality
one body is too many but nowadays like
that pearl would say we're praying for
under five bodies right because the
girls that were the girls that were
meeting now 10 20 30 40 as you get older
the bodies will keep no but your face is
like that but how do you think we feel
we feel we feel we feel like that yeah
because historically men had to ensure
paternity
so it's like we may live in a modern era
but it doesn't undo their wiring and
their their predisposition to be
disgusted by by a girl that's a hoe
because historically they didn't know if
that kid was theirs
so they could be passing on their
resources and their time and their
energy into a kid that's not even theirs
okay okay and then on top of that like
if you've slept um if a girl's a virgin
she has an 80 chance of a happy marriage
after 10 years where if she slept with
more than five people it drops down to
30 percent which i think most guys would
pray for
nowadays
but that's because they don't know good
sex because the guy has nothing to
compare to or the woman doesn't have
yeah but why do why do we want why would
you that's true
like why would you want to compare
someone to your husband
like what what what good does that do
you if you're telling me that i don't
know good sex what you're also saying to
me i'm not no no not like that not me
personally but when you're saying that
in order for to know good sex a woman
has to have multiple partners then
you're just saying to us you're being
run through no not multiple partners i'm
saying like the how would you the
marriage no the marriage is obviously
going to be better because you don't
know any better
yeah but that's yeah that's good
i'm not arguing against it because
because imagine this right yeah like
you're like i don't know any better but
it could be better but i don't know it's
better but what if it is now you're
living in that what if but you actually
have something really good that's there
right and that so if you're slept with
if you're slept with 20 guys for example
right yeah they'll say it doesn't matter
but if i'm the 21st guy i'm now
comparing to 20 other guys like
different sizes different sexual
techniques now i might be good or
whatever but what are the chances are
that after 20 guys that at the 21st guy
i'm going to be able to be the one that
does it for you well yeah i agree
yeah makes a good point and how many and
how many girls
and how many girls have an ex they can't
get over
or you know you know damn well that girl
is with that guy but she doesn't want
him that's like every guy's worst fear
because guys are like they don't know
like they don't know the difference
because girls or girls can play a part
easy
and
who are you thinking of i can see it in
your eyes
who are you thinking of
no but that like
it wasn't
because like okay in that example yeah
like which one tell me names
like
let's say like i can now meet you yeah
you may not have had like
let's say my body count is 20. god
forbid she's um he's got 20 years okay
cool this guy's it's not
[Music]
but let's say is that like i've met you
i've now i've now had
tyrone with the niner and the the
or whatever
tyron not back nobody wants that let's
be honest but like let's but now i'm now
looking at you
for your personality because i've been
there done that had that
do you know what i mean like i'm now
looking for the the other qualities in
you yeah but like so
it's that's they talk about it in the
rational male where it's like the alpha
and the beta so you're looking for a
provider you're looking for a more
stable guy where you're looking for the
hot guy to begin with yeah and i've seen
what he can do and he can't do anything
yeah but like a part of you is still
gonna want that depending on where you
are in your cycle
so like i don't remember exactly where
it's at but like you you crave different
traits based on where you are in your
cycle
and so when you i think so i think it's
like when you're ovulating you start to
crave like more of the like super hot
guy
not me where i'm at now in my life i
prefer
but
um i prefer the
the man that is let's say like not as
sexually as experienced because um
yeah but that's that's the point like
most guys don't want to be the guy you
want to be like stable with they want
they want to be the guy that you're like
super hot for
like that you that you just find him so
stupid attractive but like once you've
had that level of guy you can't find
that level of guy that stupid attractive
anymore
and that's why that's why that's what
they always talk about it's not
necessarily about the number of bodies
it's like the quality it's it's a weird
concept but it's like basically like she
might have slept with five people but if
one of them was i don't even know who
jason momoa is but apparently he's a
really attractive i like seriously don't
know who he is but that's the example
there is
no i don't really watch movies so i
don't i watch youtube
yeah
good but if he one of them is jason
momoa it's like that girl's ruined for a
lifetime because she's always going to
want jason momoa who comes after that
even i was thinking about this the other
day blake lively seems so so wifey but
she's still leonardo dicaprio's
leftovers
so ryan ryan reynolds is with her now
who does she really want i didn't even
remember that leonardo and blake yeah
like five years or something yeah and so
it's not necessarily about the number
but like as he was saying if it's 20
what are the odds that you're the best
out of 20
yeah but jason there's a reason why
jason momoa is no longer there
i don't i don't know who he is like i
just think i i think it's a lot for a
man to be putting on the line right and
i just think as men you're not coming to
us with virginity so already you're not
coming with that and a lot of times then
you're coming with with with other extra
stuff so these little these little
things that we're asking for is because
we're quite aware that once a woman has
had that what do you call it alpha widow
don't you call it is that what you've um
you call it alpine once a girl's been
alpha widowed it's like you're coming as
the guy after that and it's never going
to be good for that and we've seen it
even if she gets in a long-term
relationship she'll end up being back
outside at some point because unless you
truly truly want to change a life
background you know i mean but most
times once a girl has a girl has
experienced something they want to go
back to that and it's just unfortunate
that that that you know there's going to
be some poor guy that's going to be the
end of it but that's how the game goes
do you think that's boys yet do you
think it's like an ego thing between us
that we don't want our girl to be
sleeping around with
all well no man should be able to tell
you what your woman looks like naked
this is what yeah this is what i'm
trying to say though this is we don't
want we don't want a girl that has slept
with three people from the area or or
two we prefer innocence
we don't want that as well what do we do
yeah all the yeah
yeah
yeah yeah all the girls that are
sleeping with drake are super concerned
about all the bodies but this is what i
mean because they say but then all these
boys that have sleep with 40 girls 50
girls how on earth do they get there how
how because men and women are not the
same this is exactly what i'm trying to
say no because end of the day like let's
let's be real right
so so
some girls are going to say a man that
slept before him i will never ever touch
him oh he's disgusting but no someone or
some girls who will purely detest them
but most girls they're going to be like
especially if the women are high quality
let's talk about the types of women if
these are high quality women most women
going to be attracted by the fact that
this man has slept with 40 high
women that they consider to be threats
and now he's chosen me women going to
find that attractive because any man
that's attracted to other women women
find you attractive no woman wants a man
that nobody else wants in fact and
that's why i always say that if not you
could pick the baiters in the comments
so i have a question for everyone all
right would you take
50 000 in credit card debt that you have
to help pay off
or 50 bodies on your partner
start with the women
so you have to work for a lifetime to
help pay off the 50 000 worth of credit
card deck or however long it takes i
don't
i don't know how long it would be
as long as their bodies are dead then
yeah
you take the bodies
um i think i would rather take the
bodies the bodies
the bodies okay but
bodies are dead
yeah the body is personally okay now
guys
all day every day i need a little bit
that's a man
sorry as a man we can clear the debt um
as a man if i'm marrying you or whatever
that's something i'll take on anyway
it's not a problem but the bodies we
cannot erase that you cannot go but that
we can clean that up we can go back and
make more money and get rid of it but
you cannot erase those 50 dicks that
been inside of you it's disgusting so i
have a question so i'm just curious at
what point so a hundred thousand dollars
in debt still so okay
is there is there ever a point where you
would pick the body like a number okay i
know you you said you make you said you
make a lot of money so let's
is there any is there ever a number
where you would pick the bodies like two
hundred thousand dollars in debt three
hundred like where's the i was just
curious i mean
two hundred thousand
because genuinely generally we can all
we can get out of debt together like we
can build yeah and yeah no come on man
that's nice
also i try to i tried to read the 50
ones quicker um pearl your super chats
are not cost effective i have something
to say about the single parent lady as i
feel she's being attacked although
somewhat factually you didn't fully
listen to her and read the between the
lines sending the rest in the text of
the chat yo the chat is too long
but okay and then the second one pearl
as a woman is ovulating she craves more
masculine dominant features conversely
when a woman isn't she is looking for a
softer more docile provider type of male
if your man isn't your number one then
he's unknowingly waiting to be replaced
okay interesting
the 50. i asked so many guys that at
carnival 50 000 in debt or 50 bodies and
they every guy said 50
almost every guy said that they would
take the body or the debt over the
bodies
what do you guys think the average body
count is for a 31 year old in london
that's the average age of first marriage
in the uk so you said eight fatty one
yeah 31.
no no 30. she's 31 years old how many
bodies do you think she got eight 25 25
25.
the average woman absolutely
absolutely
i i i don't mean it in a disrespectful
way i know 12. i know students in school
that have body counts of 10 and they're
only 16 years old
that's sad it is very sad but it's very
common but unfortunately it's the world
we live in nowadays there are 16 and 17
year olds out here that are just
slinging it around that's just the world
we live in nowadays so i would take it
that the average body plant would be
about you see you said you say eight i
don't know what what the teacher said
maybe
i don't know now okay what are you doing
my generation would probably be eight
okay eight
would you say twelve
yeah i'm speaking for other people the
average the average body cam but yeah 12
12 okay 25
25 to 35 25 to 35 seriously um i would
probably say between 10 and 15 10 and
15.
i don't
i mean i
i'm gonna google it for shits and
giggles but i
i think if you put an average body count
if you can't cut your body cart on your
hands but may i ask how would we be able
to tell that this is true no i know and
you wouldn't that's right that's why i
said i don't have the answer um it says
nine point eight
that's this is closest
the average person's body count and then
another one says four and eight
yeah but the problem is i feel like they
don't really get the data like
how do i put it
like the newer generation like a lot of
the data sets i see were from like 10
years ago and like it's just a different
type of madness from like 10 years ago
can i say on that point in the american
pie film that came out in about 2 000
even some of the characters said oh but
isn't it for men that you divide it by
three but for women you times it by fee
for bodybuilding yeah i mean you never
actually no but
i was just curious i feel like it's more
like you get more realist realistic
answers when you just ask people on the
streets because it's like then they
answer more i don't know
um okay i'm gonna read super chats one
more time and then
i think we're gonna close out the show
um
okay um watch zach bears
i'm sorry okay call me waj okay i'm
gonna do that or rearranged alphabet
guys who pay for these picks on
instagram will use those picks for one
reason if you benefit financially from
it you are pimping you are a beta um
okay
think of it think of it this way i've
got to disagree she's not posting
anything naked
or i guess i guess i wonder if he would
put andrew tate as a beta then did you
do
that
i don't know if it ends up a billionaire
then he's not a beta
but he can't be a billionaire beta but
what but what basically it's just i
understand i understand you're like i'm
not searching and going around here
taking pictures of them again i
understand what i understand what you
mean by it like you're comfortable
you're like she's making money but i'm
also trying to flip on the other side
it's like as a man
as a man we don't want some random guy
first of all paying for pictures of our
girl and then the second of all having
the rights to do whatever he wants and
exploit those pictures in whatever way
he was you're not talking like he's some
naked no it doesn't have to be that he
doesn't know what he's doing well he can
do whatever he wants
like i said
i don't really think it's just that
that's the point i think the point
really is that i mean like andrew tate
is earning a lot of money so his girl
can probably go out and do that because
he earns so much money that he doesn't
have to
he doesn't have to be depending on the
300 pounds for them to go up for a nice
day he'll just do that for her whereas
like the man
as it looks to me personally it does
look like a bit of a better mill thing
i'll be honest with you okay
because like because like you should
just be paying for the dates for your
girlfriend
you shouldn't be you shouldn't be
depending on how to bring her money for
you to be like okay well maybe we can go
on a night she's i'm not trying to be
rude i don't think she's looking at you
out of respect for doing that you should
just be paying for it okay so when when
you guys put when you guys post your
selfie pictures on
for free yeah do you not think if you
post the same selfie picture with and
you get 300 pounds don't you think it's
a little bit better than doing it why
are you if you're in a relationship and
you're posting selfies on your instagram
why are you doing that
why you do why are you why are you in a
relationship when you're posting selfies
on your instagram unless you're getting
paid for it why are you doing that
i think there's a she's not she's not
being naked she's not got her toes out
she she ain't got nothing she's still
mine her body is mine
yeah her body's not yours because you
just sold it no that's the thing
listen to my words it's a selfie of her
face not her body but what is the
difference between that and prostitution
but then what is the difference between
you guys posting a selfie picture and
doing it out of nothing you're just
doing it the point is
yeah it's narcissistic one is
narcissistic one's out there trying to
pimp your wife no that's the thing i'm
not trying to go okay it's like it's
like i could walk down the street anyone
could take a picture of my feet but if
i'm sending someone a picture knowing
they're going to jack off to my feet i
just feel like it's a different thing
and i know and i know and i know someone
could yeah
why would you do not
both no i'm not okay but even if he gave
me money to get pictures to jack off to
my feet i still know that's what he's
doing like you think i haven't gotten
some weird ass requests send me off
honestly
i'll be
asking where i live
i just see it as if if women post 10
selfies a week and don't get paid for it
and you're in a relationship
why don't you do that and get paid for
it yoga you're focused too much on the
monetary value bro we need to get rid of
this no no no no no no no but why have
you why did you why are you letting your
girl have an instagram
i think it's more of the symbolism no
bro like end of the day
just take the money out of it the act of
you have to be aware that there's
probably a man that's ejaculating and
busting over your girl's face literally
over a picture of her face that's let me
let me bring it why are you putting your
face like that why not carry on
i want you to understand what happens on
the internet so if you try to make it
out to be like it's some innocent thing
no someone is paying because they're
getting such a gratification out of your
wifey and not her feet her feet i might
be like you know girl listen let's get
some money to give her her actual face
where she walks down with me in the road
people
funny
but you gotta put this way bro men can
can jerk off to anything they can just
look at a girl's picture in a nice
little dress and they
okay but there's a difference between me
just walking down the street anyone can
jack off like can do that take a picture
of you jack off and there's a difference
between giving someone a picture you
know they're going to no but that's the
thing
you don't you don't know you guys are
assuming that's what the other guys do i
don't know what he's doing with these
pictures as long as she hasn't got her
body on you no no no no
you died
you stop stop it stop you're actually
like a woman right now she's actually
like a woman
like that like come on you know that you
know stop the cat brother
that's that's
that i heard for this that is quite
perfect why would a man pay at twenty
thousand dollars for a ring for a girl
that he could literally pay five pounds
for to seal any fans
is it not the same thing definitely not
the same thing darlene um
because when you post when you're in a
relationship and you post 10 selfies on
your instagram why are you doing that
but the whole point is that you are you
don't know why are you posting 10
selfies on instagram and you're in a
relationship why are you doing that
i don't think he should be like exactly
so this is what i'm trying to say so if
you are going to do that you might as
well make is she
is she doing it anyway
no no no she wasn't doing anything yeah
so i'm saying like
why would you but it was not like we
were searching for like modern ladies no
but you said you said she was private
and you told her to take it off private
yeah and then after taking off private
three three weeks later because they
take attention it's currently yeah
why must why can't you create something
a brand or a business and you get
attention and you create currency from
that why are you using your wifey as a
brand of business i don't understand
you're pimping your girl but this is
where you guys are going straight away
because you don't think i'm a people
you're like
we're fighting about having our girls
having instagram so i said if my girl's
going to have instagram you might as
well make it count no but that is
pimping bro it's another word of pimple
you you're just you know what you're
doing you know what you're doing what
you're trying to do is when people say
you know what yeah it's it's not
escorting but you know what they call my
phone and i go but it's the exact same
thing you are pimping your goal and
there's a guy out there that's paying
300 pounds and you are giving them
facial pictures of your misses and then
he's having the legal right to exploit
them and distribute in whatever way
you could go on instagram and do the
same thing for free this is what i'm
trying to say
but it's like you said your girl wasn't
doing that so if she wasn't if she
wasn't if she wasn't posting pictures of
her face in a relationship
like she wasn't in that position and
then you said go in that position yeah
because basically how i look at
instagram it's not a dating website i
think it's an op
it's an opportunity to better your
career on instagram this is not tinder
this is not grinder this is instagram
instagram's not a dating website solely
but what was her career though
no no it's not talking about me as well
as opportunities that instagram brings
no i'm saying i'm saying
like look look like like
not plugged
these are my drinks right i would look
to instagram to figure out a way to to
distribute monetize and to promote my
drinks right why don't you think of a
way to create something where you can go
out there and make money from instagram
why are you
remember that's the [ __ ] teacher
she's the oldest in no way i just want a
second for me bro because you're getting
it wrong no i'm getting it right because
if anyone on my bridge and said yo bro
i'm just selling pictures of my girl on
the oh you think i'm saying it like that
though that's the thing i said i think
we should just leave this conversation
you know not that i really do i don't i
think it's just just agree to do it you
can't you okay you you see what he's
trying to say and i can see what you're
doing if your girl's gonna post ten
pictures you might sell people in
[Laughter]
okay i'm gonna stop stop i'm gonna read
i'm gonna read super chats um okay mark
get glazers out pearl i want to get to
know linda she's speaking my language
intelligent articulate and wants to grow
her own food and homeschool let's go
guys
i i get a lot of messages
i get i got a lot of a lot of people
liked linda um
and
the thing is
i get so many messages i can't hook you
up with every guest but you know who
does eddie dm eddie
um h vargas 207 and alpha doesn't care
what she makes dragon stallion one zero
zero one dude in the black have you ever
heard of a tribute pick jayla rosa um
that's your wife girl woman you're
selling her image a man works to provide
for his wife not sell her pennies
stop
stop ski mask um i'm sexually an active
30 year old dude my body count is
already eight my social my friend circle
is much more active um why is your boss
sasuke call me oh i read that one
already okay as as the rules were now
you can speak your piece about the super
chat yeah i know i think
i feel like everyone's like
thinking that i
sat down with my bird and said listen
open up your private account so we can
attract all this attention that's what
you said you did though no
can i can i save my bit please
yeah so what i said to what i'm saying
is that if you've got instagram you're a
beautiful girl you can monetize off that
so if you've got instagram why do you
get off private and see what you can
what opportunities are out there for you
i mean why why i mean you you guys have
different views than me i don't know but
i'll put it this way if my if i see a
girl posting 10 pictures
and she's and she's getting all this
attention
why don't you get why do you get some
money out of that
i'm not i'm not telling i'm not telling
you guys
didn't do that bro like can't you just
love your girl and just have it as a
girl like why i should have to make you
pee it's not that deep bro i'm not
talking about love and i'm talking about
her having an instagram account no but
i'm saying i'm saying why do you have to
monetize your girl why can't she just be
a girl and being her your girls are good
enough and as long as she's loyal she's
not out in the streets she'll get me
she's not getting a high body and that's
good enough but that's the thing because
you know what you're doing now bro i'll
be honest with you you're you are
actually tempting fate you'll put your
girl out to instagram but you have to
understand the type of men that are out
on instagram you have no idea because
you actually don't understand at any
given moment a guy with a blue tick and
men with blue ticks do this all the time
to average men they go in your goals dm
and they will gas up your goal now if
you're an average guy and you're
allowing your goal to be exposed to all
of these like remember all these rappers
all these people that you said and your
girl is actually a pretty girl bro
you're inviting everything because the
type of men that will come into you are
going to make you feel very small i
wouldn't do it personally you know what
i think i think no i i agree with you
but with me
i'm just like if she she can get
any blue tick in there are you are you
married to her no she's not yours balls
just okay
it's just your turn bro until you marry
her she does not belong to you bro and
another man will come and say you ain't
got a ring on it so like where's your
man okay so so you're you're a woman you
haven't married out on the gram and
drake and dm at any given time no
because i know i don't know i know my
girl and i said to her he did it before
and
the the man thought he knew that he was
going
it was like it was there together like
seven eight years but this is what i'm
trying to say
all i'm trying to say is that if she
entertains it back
that's where the red flag is
you're dangling
when you if you're with a beautiful girl
and she's walking down the road yeah no
one's dangling any carrots this is
what's up this is what okay okay but
there's a difference between walking
down the road and where it could happen
and putting a for sale sign
and then and then you're saying you're
saying you know what you should put on a
first sale sign because you never know
what business ventures we could you
could do let's let me do something else
right this is how it goes right free
boots for a picture if i've got money
for 300 pound for a picture what how
much more money have i got to offer now
now you get put in a place where money
and morals money and morals how much
money do you have versus the moles you
have i already know 300 pounds you're
willing to send me a girl's picture and
i already know that right so now the
girl's willing to do that so she's
willing to exchange pictures of herself
for money now you put yourself in a very
precarious situation my brother because
in reality now if you're dealing with
the types of men that as you know you
come from a family top one percent types
of men that have money as as
you know i mean as much one is
disposable um the rich guys i know i
promise you they're not spending money
can ask a question so what pictures did
she have for those men to know that she
was so pretty what picture was she
posing before just selfies like this oh
on her instagram just selfies here just
selfies like this and that's what and
then one guy messaged her and i said no
it doesn't that doesn't matter
no before so
i said no you're actually a beautiful
girl
open it up and see what you see or we
can monetize it what's the point having
social media and all these apps if we're
not gonna get anything out of it okay
what is the point of it would you want
attention all the time
you want to post 10 selfies a week and
get attention and likes
come on no you're her agent you know man
i
prefer but when you post a picture get
selfies no because posting up a picture
there's a bit of narcissism about it
there's a little bit i want to feel
listen listen we'll give you that we can
give you these little bits if i'm going
to give you something paul i'll give you
that little discretion once you get past
that bit where we all want to fill up
it's fine that's human nature once you
get into the point of where you're now
taking
certain pictures for men for exchange of
money it's it's
it's a start of something my brother and
if you don't understand even as a man
how your wife or your missus will look
my man don't mind me sending pictures of
myself he put me in my camera about me
though
and it's very naive to just explain
like i'm just under the opinion that
like no woman is special and you just
have to protect your relationship
because you never know
and there are a good woman out there but
in the wrong situation they might do the
wrong thing yeah i mean there are you've
got to just put trust in your woman to
be fair i don't i think it's i think
it's all and i understand you're saying
but you sound like you're explaining the
girl that you do not trust at all
because i like my girls i don't trust
you i don't trust myself my girl do you
have these things on the balls but i
trust you remember they come down to the
bugatti thing again right i have a
bugatti it is the best car in the world
it's the most expensive car in the world
you don't trust the locks
no i do trust the locks but i'm not
going to leave my um um my bugatti in
the ghetto to get me no matter how much
i trust the locks i know that at some
point when you leave something like that
in a place where people are not used to
seeing things like that there's a chance
where someone's going to attempt to do
something to it and what you're doing is
you're handing in your bugatti and
you're advertising it and you're saying
you are you can come and have a piece of
my bugatti for 300 pounds bro but people
do
and hopefully and hopefully you'll bring
it back
you can even you can even do that or
they can do it for free because either
way boys are doing it on your instagram
there is something they're doing that
for free there's something there's
something that you said that didn't
really add up i thought you said she
didn't have selfie pictures on there
yeah and then and then later you were
like oh she had she had a private
account but she asked what was the
pictures before you made it on private
and i said it was only selfie but was
she posting those in the relationship
because i thought you said she wasn't
that's what i was confused
because earlier i said was she posting
selfies in the relationship and then you
said no no that's the thing that she's
not she doesn't post it on her timeline
that's the thing so what i want to know
is
because what i think pearl's trying to
say is her profile was private
so how did you know that she could get
paid for money if you don't know how
boys work no but you said one guy
approached no use okay okay i think you
said one guy approached her and said how
did this guy approach her was it if she
was private how did you know that he was
going to pay
no he
you know he said that he
his partner put his um high instagram on
public because he told her to yeah
no i suggested that i didn't yeah
suggested whatever yesterday i said why
haven't you got that then she then
within a month someone contacted her and
said i can pay you they want to know
what her instagram is in the chat
nobody said i know what's happening
is there as many points no no no no
let's let's
put our instagram yeah
yeah yeah hold on a second you got the
super chats going actually men actually
want to contribute to what you've been
talking about and i don't want to give
the gram no yeah
they want to look and not pay that's the
thing no they want to pay they're just
paying no this is something
listen listen i'm not going to blast my
girl
you're capping stop the cat bro i'm not
capping bro i'll tell you your girl will
post 10 pictures on instagram and i'll
get paid i'll rather michael post 10
pictures on instagram and get paid for
it okay in a relationship
okay so she's not going to do that get
off instagram okay okay you can you can
sell the picture simple that's fine
that's fine if you can okay
so that's that's fine that's fine that's
fine that's fine that's the stop stop
that's fine that's fine okay i'm gonna
ask you guys another question i was
gonna close out the show but i had this
question i thought was pretty good
um
how has social media distorted people's
perceptions and expectations of what sex
and intimacy is supposed to be
jeez
no no
what about you being a little quiet
is it because i put the red flags by you
i deleted some i got rid of some i
appreciate it
um what was the question sorry how has
social media distorted people's
perceptions and expectations of what sex
and intimacy are supposed to be
um
well i feel like my
personal opinion on sex is that
it's
an art form
and i feel like it's a very spiritual
experience and it's a very intimate and
personal experience between men and
women
and it's like
i feel like on social media
it's been portrayed to be something that
should just be
expected or given away or it's portrayed
to be something that
it's just like it's nothing like
to meet a man and have sex with him
right now is just
so like don't get me wrong it's okay
because that's a personal choice for you
as a woman but
for me i just feel like
to let somebody
into you on
such an
are you thinking about intimate no no no
one no one but i just feel like to let
someone inside of your body like
people that for me people don't
really deep it like so do you think
social media has made it more casual yes
way
way way more casual like there was a
point where sex was only expected after
marriage
now it's
after a dm or two do you know what i
mean so it's just to me it's been
downgraded so much and it's lost its
value
and i think
as someone
i just feel like yeah sex has lost its
value a lot especially because of how
much sex has been portrayed through
music
just people just in general do you know
what i mean like
i don't know
i don't know okay what about what are
you what are you i don't know who you
follow on social media but i don't see
any of that i've got goofy stuff on my
instagram like i don't see any
expectations of sexual whatsoever
because
you don't see you don't see it what are
you what are you talk you don't see the
girls with their ass pics oh
what does that have to do with sex
though
sex and sexuality well what is that well
that that signals sexual availability to
a guy that's like that's like what a
girl's doing she's saying she's
signaling that i'm sexually available to
men and so that where does that lead
but it's so it's so common now i don't
like
i don't associate with sex anymore
because the way like like tia said like
the way
we view sex is like a spiritual thing
like i'm not looking at your physical
when it i'm not thinking about your
physical when it comes to sex when it
comes to actual making love
i'm not thinking like i'm i'm looking up
but do you think that's like a woman's
point of view because i i think guys
it's more just like a handshake
that's what i've heard what's the man's
point of view
just repeat the question is it is sex a
spiritual thing for you guys no
no not not at all
not i think i think we enjoy the chase
more than the sex
i don't i don't know it sounds like you
guys are trying to try to put too much
on it man like women don't treat sex to
spiritual thing like women are so
empowered sex yeah but making love like
actual
what was the last
last time you made love but basically i
don't
making love is the movies when you grow
up you watch movies oh i'm making love
and real life you don't make love like i
don't know what
do you i mean
no i was going to say yeah if you're a
virgin on your wedding night yeah yeah
but
but if you're not a virgin on your
wedding night like what you you're
getting your butt blown out that's about
it so i'm saying no but that's good but
that's what you want if it goes like oh
you know he was he was being too gentle
but i wanted to i wanted and that's
really what you want right
now we had an only fans guy on the show
and he said his number one requested um
like thing is is grape like grape
fantasies from women that's his number
one request okay so i'm not like i know
that's an extreme but it just shows like
what women want you know any man you
know any man that's been been with been
with women and you will start discover
that women like certain things in
controlled environments like you get me
and if they become more comfortable with
you you're going to discover some of
these crazy things they're like you know
what i'm saying i'm a bit of a freak but
it's because a lot of times women do
want to fill in these scenarios where
they can get themselves out of it and
they know it's safe so when a woman
wants you to grab her throat or do all
these things where you think oh that's a
bit whatever it's because generally like
she wants that but she wants to have it
in a controlled environment where she
can also be like no actually you know
what i mean so yeah like um
but do you think that social media gives
women unrealistic expectations similar
to what we just witnessed yes
every type of unrealistic
expectation on us
i think it's the media too like like
disney type [ __ ] disney definitely
100 like i think love marriage is
supposed to be boring
like the thing i always hear about is is
is happiness right i'm happy i'm not
happy but
you know what rp rp the queen i'll play
lizzy but one thing i'll take from the
queen passing away right no matter what
you think of her it's the duty that she
did now so when you look at the rest of
the royal family they just do whatever
they want they don't want to stick out
to do what she what she went and did
because in reality that's a very boring
existence it's not what it's not it's
not you picking the man you want to
marry picking the woman you want to
marry it's not you living your best life
no it's going to be years and years of
duty you're never going to do any
interviews you're not going to have a
point of view and it's going to be like
that and the rest of them will be like f
that and i think
i saw it in social media a lot of modern
women they don't have duty anymore and
they don't have the thing what the queen
had and that was like regardless of
what's going on i'm gonna i'm gonna
stick it out and i'm gonna go and do
this and when i look at my mum and my
dad my dad um
my dad was a diplomat from the cameroon
embassy and he's also back where i come
from cameroon he's the paramount ruler
so he's the chief of all chiefs
so we come to this country because of my
dad and like
for me like
like i don't know like when i just look
at
i lost myself it's fine
i just you know this i'm just thinking
about my dad and i was thinking about
the sacrifices that my dad did my mom
did and there's not there's no there's
no one doing anymore my dad like a lot
of african people that came first
generation or um there might have been
one person that came first and the other
person stayed over there my dad was
quite fortunate because of his job he
was back and forth back and forth the
things that i saw my mom have to do
as a strong woman are it's not things
that many women would want to do today
being separated from your husband but
because of her doing that thing now her
children were able to go on to become
barristers to go on to become business
people to go and become doctors but
that's because of one woman's um
sacrifice what i'm trying to say to you
and do you so that's one of the things
that that i think that's missing i would
agree i would actually say that duty
comes first before love when you're
actually serious about someone in that
respect i mean i was raised by my
grandparents and i saw that my entire
life my grandma was so beautiful to my
grandad even in sickness she was by his
deathbed looking after him every single
day and i think that love was developed
from that
i think women from the 1950s 40s 30s
would think we're so weak today she's
like she's like you left because you
weren't half happy my man had a side
side family across town
yeah she's like and i stuck it out
so i met i met the other half out of his
funeral you know and it's like i even
talk about like my family like my mom
got pregnant when she was 17 by my dad
and they ended up giving up the kid for
adoption but she stuck it out with him
and they ended up getting married later
and it's like a lot of girls like
they don't have the like grit to stick
it out when they're not happy and when
[ __ ] goes south and
um
i don't know i think it's it's sad
because the kids are the one oftentimes
you have to suffer
um but i'm gonna read the i'm gonna
actually close out the show so if anyone
has any you know peace i feel like i i
have a feeling i know who's not sure
no if anyone has any final thought no no
not yet not yet not yet
hold it in hold it okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna read the super chats first
and then everyone's gonna get a chance
to say any final thoughts
you know you can you can put whatever
okay das token e30 only rich people
understand duty duty is hard how
eligible as a christian i believe that
social media has ruined many people's
perception of what healthy sexuality and
intimacy is sex is for marriage and
marriage isn't just for sex um
paper chasing ask them ask how they
would get and keep a man without sex
columbian ashes a fine girl 50 plus
bodies or a virgin lizzo
for a life marriage gentleman at least
he is a kind pimp he's too natural to
self thought
h vargas 207 pearl i know you know how
to drive a car i'm not worried about
your driving i'm just worried about the
other drivers
dragon one set stallion one zero zero
one if she posts selfies for three
hundred dollars what will she do for
fifty thousand dollars
stop it it's okay i keep telling you
andrea d dude when you are referring to
when you refer to your girl as a bird
and monetizing her face you need to
learn to respect her what you have is
not a relationship neo-moses what's
eddie's info so i can reach out to linda
everyone loved linda um dm it's his
instagram should be in the description
but if it's not it's on my um bio just
dot pearly things that's my instagram so
his um instagram's in my bio matt
butcher i think one important thing we
haven't touched on is why people do the
ig the psyche of it the constant need
for attention and validation how
unhealthy is colombian ashes a girl with
50 plus bodies or virgin lizzo for lying
um marco glazer's out pearl i want to
get to know linda she's late she's
speaking my language intelligent
articulate wants to grow her own food at
homeschool let's go
um h vargas and alpha doesn't care what
she makes okay so now
any final pieces that you guys want to
say you could start any final thoughts
this was very interesting
that's what i have did you girls learn
anything anything new today that you
didn't know before
did you
i learned that men don't make love
i learned that
now i actually did because to me i feel
like there is definitely a difference
between having sex and making love with
someone and
making love doesn't equate to slow sex
making love is just
when there's a real depth behind the
action
in that you know that you're taking and
you can feel that connection to the
person on a level beyond the physical
sex is just the physical like i'm just
here to
get what i need and go making love i i
want to feel you you know i mean and to
know that men don't
feel like that as well it's interesting
it's changed my perspective today this
is new
that's just him
yeah
i didn't say that no but he's speaking
like he's been no
no no i'm telling you
men can have sex with animation no wait
i don't know how we got that how did we
get that
man
he's speaking on behalf of all men no
wait wait he was speaking you said men
don't deliver no no no no don't meet
club no no no no no paul let me just let
me clarify of course men make love like
i'm not saying men don't make love but
we're going to make love to our wife and
to the woman we want to be with but if
you're just one of these girls we're
going to bang you and we're going to
blow your back out that's a difference
like there's something that that you
reserve for your wife like all for this
things that we got a reserve that i
swear to god there's some things that
we've got to reserve
that's all i meant
but i don't think i don't think from the
whole of this thing you should get that
that's what you should take from this i
think from all of this you should
probably take that
men do want do men do want to be one
wives they don't want relationships but
they want women that are wives and
what's he saying in the bible um the man
that finds a wife finds a good thing
that suggests your wife already when i
find you so which means i'm a husband
already i want to meet a woman that's
good to go i don't need a woman that's
been run through that's you know that's
decided that actually oh she's got a
child already or she decides actually in
the mid 30s now i want to pick you when
she's depict me when i was trying to
grind and build my business but she
didn't did she she picked up other guys
now my business is doing well and things
are going well all of a sudden i become
someone that she wants to pick but guess
what i have a
i have now a lot of interest from other
people and younger girls as well so why
do i have to pick you then we get
that's not always the case though that's
not always the case but i do believe
like and what i experienced a lot of my
friends who are all in this predicament
like um a lot of them are doing well for
themselves but at the time when they
women were supposed to look at them they
didn't look at them do you feel like you
would not give a girl loyalty because
she wasn't there alone no i wouldn't
know i would that's not about because
there's still many more things to do
right i was just wondering no some guys
say if she's not there along the way
then yeah no i think i think if you
if you become i'm not i'm not a
millionaire so if you go and do
something and you become become really
rich or really successful overnight i
think then i might be slightly a little
bit more like okay cool but at the same
time as a man we don't
if you didn't like me when i never had
no money that's okay as well because
if i wanted a woman that was a certain
level i wasn't on that level and i had
to gain my value and i understand that i
don't think that's bad that another guy
that had a more value at me at the time
could get that that's that's the name of
the game it's not fair i need to level
myself up to a position where i can meet
those types of women whereas a lot of
times women want things to be fair when
us us as men know that if a next man is
at a higher level at the moment all i
got to do is
build myself up and get myself to that
level if that's not now when i was 17 18
we had to watch all the men in their 20s
and 30s take all the women it wasn't
nice we didn't have cars we didn't have
certain things but we had to watch it
and we didn't get bitter what did we do
we got better so now when it's us now no
one should be getting any feelings yeah
but that's that's the motivation because
let's say for example
using yourself as an example
i
took a leap of faith and went with the
person that
didn't have that and that was gonna
get there like the person that you're
saying and they had already got me
so they didn't feel the need to continue
to working hard to do you know what i
mean and that's one thing i want to say
men the rent is due every single day
yeah just because the worst thing you
could possibly do is get the woman of
your dreams yeah because now you've got
you have to keep on even if you keep her
interest for the first few years you
manage to get the worst thing you can do
is get a baby out of her now you're like
you feel like she's yours okay
you got the woman of your dreams and if
she is that badness when you let her out
like you said she's gonna get another
man or be outside so this thing where
men feel they can lie to a woman push a
rental do certain things get the woman
then they think they know that like you
don't own that woman and the moment you
fall off your job i do believe i don't
mean like instantaneously a woman should
stand by a man but if you're not willing
to keep levitating an elephant no man
exactly the game's the game hasn't
happened you lose her clicks
aggressively
okay is that was that your final thought
yeah i don't know yeah so basically yeah
no like obviously um yeah thank thank
you paul for having us on the show i
feel like like not even i feel like i
know that it was a good show like i've
definitely learned some perspective from
other people i do take things on
involved like to be honest you brought
up same
but i'm never gonna agree what you're
telling me
but from the ladies i did take i did
take a lot obviously you being i'm a
single mother as well like i just want
to just put that out i was i was never
taking those shots at you i was just
saying generally like as men you know i
mean i was catching like that because i
am too a single what i'm saying yes and
it's not that quiet in it
oh yeah
i was just i just wanted to hear what
you thought about me
with like
certain things you did say was like i
don't know i've never heard it before
because i've never had a man come to me
and tell me oh
i can never date a woman it's a turn off
having someone that has kid is literally
new to me might i might see on like i
don't know on tv or something but i've
never had someone in my bed but then
when i realized that you don't have kids
not in a room but not a negative you
don't have kids you're 38 years old
like
so it kind of feel like you don't have
much options in that aspect no i've got
a lot of questions
let me let me finish speaking please let
me finish speaking because a lot of
people people in my generation
have kids
yeah have kids i don't know
my friendship group probably one of us
don't have a kid yeah but and
a lot of us have had kids younger
yeah it'll be nice for us to grow up
with our partner that whatever but
situations happen at no point growing up
was it ever good like like so how are
you twenty i'm
yeah so okay so at no point ever was it
ever good to have a baby at our wedding
no i want no one no one ideally thinks
to themself when they get pregnant do
you know what i'm going to have a child
at weather but you have to understand
situations no i don't have to understand
you're no moment no no no no no no no no
no
hold on let me land when i say you have
to understand situations happen
situations do happen situation
they do happen it never happened to me
it never happened to my boy that's
sitting over there why don't you accept
that there's there's there's 41 forms of
birth control you could like you
couldn't yeah
so so wait wait let me let me if there's
41 forms of birth control it's like it's
not just a situation that happens it's a
choice my daughter right now she's nine
years old yeah for me having my child
save my life because
the minute she was born
the ten months after i went to uni i
thought oh you know i'm going to do
better with myself i'm going to go uni i
graduated i became a school teacher i
left this if i did not have her
i'd probably be in the streets i'd
probably be raving because i've got more
time on my hand i'll be doing this so
for me
it's
it can be a really good thing like it
was it was a benefit so when you're
looking at it like it say oh oh i can't
see the woman who has kids it's just
like well yeah because you're looking
you're looking at it from a woman's
point of view like like the point is
it's just never going to be a guy's
first choice yeah and and that's and
that's okay but when you point it out
like it's a negative no but it is not
like it's a negative because as a woman
i'm not as a woman i'm not going to see
a man and it is a double standard and
it's really sad in that aspect i'm not
going to look at a man and be like do
you know what he's got four kids three
different baby moms i'm going to argue
but you should though no i'm gonna
should that's not mommy i'm not sure
i'd like to say i don't know
i don't know
you should you should discriminate
against no no i don't know
everyone for me i stitch everyone has a
pass
i might be the woman i might be the
woman that he will change for or he
can't do nothing but i don't think
future's gonna change for anyone like
what i mean change
listen my dad has 10 children yeah 10
children yeah how many baby moms
two
two big moms my mom's got nine kids by
my dad and we've got one kid like she's
like in the middle could i never
like she's in the mix she's in the
middle do you i mean
that's it like so
i'm not going to judge my father because
of one mistake that he has done because
i'm going to dismiss all the good things
all the benefits that he has done no i'm
not you're probably a really good mother
you've come out you've become a tea
you've gone to uni you've never got a
school teacher your success right yeah
yeah but you can't no you can't detect
someone from from i don't know
but he's just being honest about how men
think and then yeah
your child saved your life yeah
but in let's say my example i was
let's say married in the eyes of the
lord i already bought my degree
he wasn't married
no
well according to the bible if the man
chooses no you're
yeah i had i had already gained my
degree my son walks across the stage
with me in my tummy i was
in a proper relationship and then it
just broke down it wasn't like
it doesn't matter how it happened and it
like you guys are you can be perfectly
nice people could have benefited your
life i mean my mom was a single mother
and
she ended up giving that kid up for
adoption but like um
it doesn't make you a bad person but men
it's not their first choice my thing is
this right i want you to understand
something when you say oh some types of
men you you girls do this because you
want to act like oh i'm anomaly or i'm
just weird i'm not weird i'm not an
anomaly men do not want to typically
date single and when we do we want to
have fun with you and the types of men
that you can have there's certain types
of men you can never have now i'm one of
them jonathan and you might not want me
but i represent a certain type of man
that will never do that and and will
vocal about it because we want girls to
know when i talk to you out in the
nightclub and you tell me i've got a
child i'm like why are you not home with
a baby before i'm not with him all of us
i'm like i'm like why are you outside
this is for the this is for the other
girls now with no kids like but you're
trying to and you're trying to be in
your 30s outside trying to fight with
the girls in their 20s and us and us men
in our 30s ain't looking at you and you
want to get mad and start saying that oh
we want to pick younger girls because we
want to manipulate them no we don't but
they're not damaged and they don't come
in with all the stuff that you've come
in an actual fact
the actual fact they look at older women
and they say they look at how you guys
are letting us fly by and how you
haven't treated us and they come and get
us and you women can't see this and and
this is the thing when a man's speaking
to you i'm saying to you listen to a man
and listen to listen to us because you
never listen to us and when we speak you
don't listen but a man is saying to you
whether or not you consider me to
represent men or not us men do not want
single mothers we don't go out there
thinking that we want a wifey single
mother's we might and if a man's got a
child of course you guys should get your
blended family and get together but you
need to leave us men with no kids alone
because
we are we need to be there for the
single women
and don't take offense to it because no
no no no one's also there's a 50 super
chat and i try to read those quicker
just my point she was talking to a guy
with two kids as in she dates guys with
kids we can all agree that if a girl
with one kid couples with a man with two
kids giving the man good feminine energy
for his family so it becomes more even
yeah yeah
i don't i don't date guys with kids
either
with me you know
no keep me out of that no but if you had
if you had a child
i have a friend like she's got a child
but she does not date men with kids and
she actually gets men with no kids
because that's that energy she's like i
don't date men with kids i don't want to
deal with their baby moms and she
doesn't she literally only gets and some
men will do that but then also when i
think to myself she hasn't got a ring
yet
so we judge about outcomes right not by
who's taking you on holidays not about
who's treating you nice we judged by the
final outcome and all throughout all of
this all i see is babies i don't see no
rings i don't see no marriages i heard a
joint account how the hell did you have
a joint account
i was in i was in a relationship with my
ex-partner for a few years it didn't
work out but he's a i don't have an
issue with him he's a good person he
looks after his daughter
but
that's it it didn't work out
do you think there's any other option
outside of marriage because marriage so
disproportionately is not advantageous
advantageous for men today i know it's
not advantageous for us people i know we
put a lot of risk up at the same time i
believe it's very important because the
reason why my my father's got three
daughters they're all married and a son
older married obviously i'll follow
suits because what i want but for a man
to you know for a man for father to have
three daughters and every single man
looked at your daughter like a wife not
a baby moms each of them said so i'm
from cameroon so um we have a diary
where we come from so traditionally so
we have a saying where we come from the
man that has many daughters is a rich
man and then the man that has many sons
of poor man i'll explain to you why this
is it's because when for example we had
three daughters so
i'm so anyone that wants to marry my
dad's my sisters would have to come and
essentially buy each you know buy each
daughter make an offering pay some money
towards the village and all the rest of
that so my dad having three daughters
will make him one of the richest men
because he would have three separate
households would have to come and buy
and put money towards the women but the
man with three sons would have to have
three separate pieces of money to go out
there to go and do it so the reason why
i say that is because there's definitely
more value in in that and the women and
we need to put that out there as well
you know what i mean paul
i understand
okay well i'm going to try to keep the
final thoughts going
um so so if you want to give your final
thoughts no it was very interesting
discussion i've learned a lot and yeah
i really enjoyed myself yeah thanks for
coming um you want to give yourselves um
final thoughts
um i believe
men will have preferences and women have
their own preferences
if you want to know what men want you
speak to men if you want to know what
women want to speak to women instead of
speaking in the same sex and deciding
which
opposite sex should believe in and what
should not
i also believe if you're in a
relationship
and
they've got social media
and they're and then and they're using
it just for attention and likes
then in a in a time like this then
have a rethink
also
yeah also i enjoyed myself here pearl
and i can't wait to show back after okay
thanks for coming um what about you
final thoughts um yeah i'd just like to
say that i really do think that
relationships are just about duty first
before love
and on on that note i'd like to say that
and i don't mean to throw anyone under
the bus here but i'm just saying things
that i was raised with personally
if you've been a woman who has a child
by a man that you're not married to then
there's no reason for you to be out here
asking for a man that's better than your
baby father
that's all i have to say on that note i
wanted to say that before i i'm sorry i
was trying to push that in there many
times but i just wanted to leave it on
that one i don't think he deserved
better than your baby father you chose
to have a child by that man
okay um i don't know where she she went
um but i i guess
no final thoughts um
okay guys um thank you for watching the
video um don't forget to like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
i'm our
is she back
okay okay do you have a final thought
your final thought
stay in school
okay guys um like the video on your way
out that is the most important metric
that youtube uses to push out these
videos so if you liked the stream you
want other people to watch the stream
make sure you like the video so people
can discover our content as you know
youtube is always trying to silence us
always trying to hold me back don't let
them like the video comment let me know
in the comments um what you agreed with
disagreed with follow our clips channels
we have just pearly clips and pearl
daily um
sign up for our memberships if you want
to see the penthouse that is the second
tier i'm also the fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month a
lot of people could use this for youtube
i'm telling you i have i've given so
many people advice from the show youtube
channels and i've gotten more people
than i can count on one hand to 10k subs
so i'm just saying um just.pearlythings
is my instagram um
dm eddie um the link to his instagram is
in the description if you want to come
on the show follow my tick tock um
first account is just pearlythings.4
second account is just pearlythings.5
follow both because i'm on my final
account warning on my fourth kick talk
so just yeah follow follow both um our
member of the week is dragon
stellium1001
check out our members only live next
week thank you for watching and i'll
talk to you next time